madame la ministre monsieur le Président
Madame et Messieurs les rapporteurs mes
chers collègues la commission des
affaires économiques et la commission du
développement durable et de
l'aménagement du territoire sont réunis
conjointement cet après-midi pour
débuter par une discussion générale
commune l'examen du projet de loi adopté
par le Sénat relatif à l'accélération de
la production d'énergie renouvelable
s'il vous plaît
je salue madame Mania spanir une hache
et ministre de la transition énergétique
qui porte ce texte et nous accompagnera
pendant une grande partie de sa
discussion la commission des affaires
économiques a déjà eu l'occasion de
mettre en oeuvre ses compétences dans le
domaine de l'énergie cet été lors de
l'examen de la loi porte en mesure
d'urgence pour la protection du pouvoir
d'achat il s'agissait alors pour
l'essentiel de voter des dispositions
visant à préserver notre sécurité
d'approvisionnement en gaz et en
électricité dans le court terme pour
faire face à une crise énergétique
résultant à la fois des conséquences de
l'agression de la Russie sur l'Ukraine
et de problèmes techniques immobilisant
la moitié de notre parc nucléaire le
projet de loi qui nous est soumis
aujourd'hui s'inscrit dans une
perspective de plus long terme visant à
décarboner notre mix énergétique pour
répondre aux défis du changement
climatique tout en accroissant notre
production d'électricité pour atteindre
ces objectifs les analyses approfondies
de réseaux de transport d'électricité
RTE publié en 2021 et début 2022 ont
clairement démontré la nécessité de
s'appuyer dans un scénario réaliste sur
la relance du nucléaire et sur le
développement des énergies renouvelables
un projet de loi récemment soumis au
Conseil des ministres permettra
d'accélérer les procédures liées à la
construction de nouvelles installations
nucléaire pour l'heure nous nous
intéressons à l'accélération de la
production d'énergie renouvelable le
projet de loi a d'abord été présenté au
Sénat après de riches discussions le
texte qui a été grandement aménagé
puisque de 20 articles dans le projet de
loi initial nous sommes passés à 93
articles le collègue du Sénat ont
notamment enrichi le texte en matière de
planification et nous aurons à reprendre
ce travail en précisant par exemple
l'élaboration des schémas de
départementaux de déploiement des
énergies renouvelables tu ne thématique
qui me tient à cœur car mon département
d'Eure-et-Loir a été le premier en
réaliser et je sais que nous pouvons
compter sur notre rapporteur pour
renforcer le texte sur le rôle central
du référent préfectoral l'élaboration
concertées de schémas de déploiement ou
encore l'opposabilité des zonages le
texte du sida a été transmis à
l'Assemblée nationale puis renvoyé à la
commission des affaires économiques par
la présidente de la trassemblée avec
Jean-Marc zulesi nous avions
préalablement convenu que la Commission
solliciterait la vie de la CDD sur de
nombreux articles du projet de loi cette
procédure prévue par l'article 87 alinéa
2 de notre règlement correspond en fait
à une délégation au fond la CDD débutera
l'examen des articles la particularité
attribué dès la fin de cette discussion
générale et se réunira mardi et mercredi
j'ai en effet accepté de ne débuter que
jeudi l'examen des articles par la
commission des affaires économiques afin
de permettre aux commissaire de la CDD
d'avoir plus de temps pour examiner le
texte en amont ça nous amènera
probablement cher collègue assiégé une
partie du week-end je vous l'annonce
comme je l'avais déjà annoncé
préalablement nos deux commissions ont
chacune désigné deux rapporteurs pour ce
qui concerne la commission des affaires
économiques il s'agit de Henri alfandary
et Eric Bothorel avant de donner la
parole au président de la CDD je vous
précise les règles d'organisation de la
DG qui correspondent aux règles
habituellement mises en oeuvre dans la
commission des Affaires échos après
l'intervention de la ministre je crois
une quinzaine de minutes chaque
rapporteur disposera de 5 minutes nous
débuterons par les deux rapporteurs de
la commission des affaires économiques
avant d'entendre ceux de la CDD les 10
orateurs de groupe prendront alors la
parole en ayant chacun 4 minutes temps
de réponse de la ministre compris c'est
ainsi que le bureau de notre commission
a décidé d'organiser les auditions afin
de donner un peu plus de rythme et
d'éviter que la personne a entendu
puisse esquiver éventuellement vous avez
donc le choix entre parler 3 minutes 110
continuer et je vous couperai la parole
pour sauvegarder une minute de réponse
vous pouvez aussi interroger la ministre
en lui posant une question courte puis
en reprenant si la réponse ne vous
satisfait pas totalement et qui vous
reste du temps libre ce sera ensuite le
tour des questions individuelles prise
d'un seul bloc et d'une durée de une
minute dans ses réponses la ministre
pourra bien évidemment si elle le
souhaite revenir sur des points soulevés
par les orateurs de groupe je souligne
enfin que nos deux commissions auront à
examiné au total près de 1900
amendements je vous remercie de votre
attention et monsieur le Président très
cher Jean-Marc vous avez la parole
merci monsieur le Président Madame la
Ministre cher Agnès monsieur le
Président merci pour vos mots Madame et
Monsieur les rapporteurs mes chers
collègues est-ce une coïncidence où
est-ce un signe nous ouvrons la
discussion générale du projet de loi sur
les énergies renouvelables au moment
même où la Coop 27 sur le climat vient
de s'achever madame la ministre ainsi
que vous l'avez déclaré l'accord
issu de cette conférence n'est pas aussi
ambitieux que nous Français et Européen
Lorient souhaité mais il préserve
l'essentiel l'objectif de limiter le
réchauffement climatique à 1,5 degrés
nous devons toujours garder à l'esprit
que le projet de loi que nous examinons
à partir d'aujourd'hui porte une double
ambition en premier lieu
décarbonées nos sources d'énergie pour
respecter nos engagements nationaux mais
aussi internationaux afin de préserver
la viabilité de notre planète il n'est
nul besoin de rappeler les catastrophes
environnementales qui ont émaillé divers
pays en 2022 au Pakistan aux États-Unis
en Australie en Europe et bien entendu
dans notre pays avec une sécheresse
historique accompagnée d'incendie de
forêt en second lieu il nous faut
retrouver une autonomie énergétique dont
l'actualité géopolitique nous rappelle
l'importance en renforçant la part des
énergies renouvelables dans le mix
énergétique aux côtés de l'énergie
nucléaire la France est clairement en
retard dans le développement des
énergies renouvelables et doit donc
donner un service coût d'accélérateur
tel est l'objet du projet de loi qui
nous est présenté aujourd'hui
madame la ministre nos deux commissions
ont préparé avec une grande attention le
débat qui s'ouvre aujourd'hui elles ont
préparé dans une bonne entente étant
tout de concernés par les dispositions
du texte et je me réjouis que Guillaume
kasbariian et moi-même ayant pu rétablir
répartir en bonne intelligence les
articles ressortant de nos commissions
respectives cette entente elle s'est
aussi matérialisée par un déplacement au
Pays-Bas pour tout simplement travailler
ensemble main dans la main sur le
déploiement de ces énergies
renouvelables la commission du
développement durable a préparé depuis
plusieurs mois l'examen du projet de loi
elle a mis en place une mission flash
trans partisane sur l'acceptabilité et
les modalités du déploiement des
énergies renouvelables permettez-moi de
rendre hommage à nos trois
corps-à-porteurs Pascal Boyer clémence
guettet et Mathilde de Paris pour leur
engagement la transmission également
procédé à plusieurs auditions et table
ronde avec des verticiens avec également
madame chantajoignot présidente de la
Commission nationale du débat public nos
rapporteurs
et Pierre Cazeneuve ont conduit leur
audition dans des délais serrés pour que
maximum d'acteurs concernés par le
projet de loi puisse faire valoir leurs
idées au Parlement
chers collègues ces auditions n'ont rien
de gratuit nous savons que le projet de
loi comprend un double défi augmenter la
part des énergies renouvelables et faire
accepter par nos concitoyens les
installations nécessaires à leur
production il y a là un enjeu de
démocratie de démocratie
environnementale dont nous ne devons
jamais oublier le fondement
constitutionnel faire accepter ces
énergies au nom de l'intérêt général de
la nécessité de supprimer les gaz à
effet de serre et de fournir à tous les
acteurs économiques et sociaux
entreprises collectivités ménages une
énergie fiable a pris réseau là
raisonnable tel est l'enjeu du projet
c'est pour cette raison que toutes ces
auditions étaient indispensables nous
avons doublé ces auditions par une
réunion hors les murs de notre
commission le 20 octobre dernier au
conseil départemental de Seine-Maritime
puis sur la base d'éolienne de fécan il
s'agissait pour nous d'évaluer avec les
élus locaux leur attente sur ce texte et
de constater comment techniquement une
base d'éolienne se met en place cette
journée a été riche d'enseignement et
des changes chers collègues je dirais
pas plus loin dans mes propos je sais
que nos débats seront passionnés mais je
ne doute pas que chaque groupe politique
aura à l'esprit les enjeux de ce texte
et que nous parviendrons à bâtir un bon
texte pour la séance publique je vous
remercie
bien merci très cher président madame la
ministre c'est à vous
Messieurs les Présidents chers Guillaume
cher Jean-Marc madame et Messieurs les
rapporteurs mesdames et messieurs les
députés voici venu le temps pour votre
assemblée d'examiner le projet de loi
relatif à l'accélération de la
production d'énergie renouvelable ce
texte qui comporte maintenant 93
articles et le fruit de discussion
exigeante au Sénat qui ont permis son
adoption à la quasi unanimité signe que
le sujet dépasse très largement les
groupes politiques mais qu'il constitue
en fait un enjeu majeur pour notre pays
et pour notre continent c'est à vous qui
revient maintenant la responsabilité de
vous prononcer sur le premier texte de
ce qu'un tenkina qui vise à apporter sa
pierre à l'objectif ambitieux fixé par
le président de la République celui de
faire de la France le premier grand pays
industriel à sortir de sa dépendance aux
énergies fossiles
ce texte répond à une double urgence
celle du dérèglement climatique qui
exige une action radicale et déterminée
notre part le GIEC ne nous donne en
effet que trois ans à l'échelle de la
planète pour commencer à baisser des
émissions de gaz à effet de serre je
veux rappeler que la France fait partie
des pays qui ont commencé à baisser leur
émission et mais que nous devons aller
plus loin c'est la position que j'ai
portée jusqu'à l'aube dimanche à la
cop27 à Charmed cher l'accord en demi
teinte que nous avons obtenu des montres
combien nous devons continuer d'avoir
une mobilisation de tous les instants
auprès de nos partenaires internationaux
je crois que cette mobilisation elle
commence ici dans notre pays c'est une
question de crédibilité si nous voulons
être écouté et entendu
ce texte c'est un moyen de montrer notre
détermination à sortir des énergies
fossiles et de renforcer notre
crédibilité dans ses négociations
internationales la deuxième urgence
c'est d'éviter une rupture
d'approvisionnement dans les mois et
années qui viennent en termes d'énergie
vous le savez la faible disponibilité de
notre parc nucléaire conjugué à la crise
ukrainienne fragilise cette année notre
système énergétique mais au-delà c'est
aussi l'avenir de notre parc nucléaire
qui se pose au regard de la durée de
fonctionnement de la durée de vie pour
lequel les réacteurs ont été construits
26 des 56 réacteurs arriveront à 50 ans
d'exploitation autour de 2035 je
rappelle que notre parc a été
initialement construit pour durer 40 ans
cela implique de prendre des décisions
aujourd'hui
ossieu bien sur la maintenance que sur
le lancement de nouveaux programmes vos
examinerez à partir de la rentrée
prochaine un projet de loi
d'accélération des procédures liées à la
production de nouvelles installations
nucléaires avant d'examiner la grande
loi de programmation énergies climat qui
vous permettra de fixer la prochaine
programmation plus réelle de l'énergie
cette dernière est précédée d'une
concertation publique obligatoire sur
notre mix énergétique elle a été lancée
il y a un mois maintenant et elle a déjà
recueilli plus de 12650 contributions
citoyennes
aujourd'hui je veux le rappeler deux
tiers de notre consommation d'énergie
finale et d'origine fossiles et
importées et je veux dissiper un mythe
nous n'avons jamais été à un quelconque
moment depuis la révolution en tout cas
depuis la Deuxième Guerre mondiale
autonome et indépendant énergétiquement
la situation avec la Russie nous
rappelle que nous pouvons être
dépendants de pays qui ne sont pas nos
alliés qui ne partagent pas nos valeurs
et qui utilise ce levier pour nous
atteindre économiquement et
politiquement notre programme nucléaire
nous a permis de réduire en partie cette
dépendance c'est vrai pour l'électricité
mais nous restons très dépendants en
matière de transport et de chaleur et je
veux dire ici aussi que notre programme
d'énergie renouvelable a permis aussi
entre 2000 et 2022 de continuer à
réduire notre dépendance aux énergies
fossiles nous sommes passées de 72% de
dépendance à peu près 65%
si nous venons atteindre la neutralité
carbone l'enjeu est donc de réduire ses
deux tiers d'énergie fossile que nous ne
produisons pas nous-mêmes et qui
contribue à la fois notre dépendance et
au réchauffement climatique c'est
pourquoi je veux être très clair sur le
combat que nous devons mener notre
combat ce n'est pas celui d'opposer le
nucléaire au renouvelable ce n'est pas
non plus d'opposer la biodiversité au
climat tant la biodiversité est affectée
par le dérèglement climatique notre
combat c'est celui des énergies bas
carbone contre les énergies fossiles car
ce sont les énergies fossiles qui sont à
l'origine du réchauffement climatique et
des principales atteintes à la
biodiversité
l'étude future énergétique 2050 des
experts de RTE rappelle que nous
disposons de trois leviers pour sortir
des énergies fossiles le développement
massif des énergies renouvelables la
relance d'un grand programme nucléaire
un projet de loi sur l'accélération des
procédures administratives va vous être
proposé je l'ai déjà dit les économies
d'énergie au travers de l'efficacité
énergétique et la sobriété énergétique
en la matière RTE fixe un objectif très
de réduction de 40% de notre
consommation d'énergie d'ici 2050 le
plan de sobriété lancé avec la première
ministre permettra de faire baisser de
10% notre consommation d'énergie de dci
2024 et vous avez au travers du projet
de loi de finance et examiner les
dispositifs en matière d'efficacité
énergétique
et je veux rappeler que la conclusion
centrale de cette étude de RTE est
atteindre la neutralité carbone est
impossible sans un accroissement massif
des énergies renouvelables même dans un
scénario maximal de relance du nucléaire
et d'économie d'énergie le texte que
nous examinerons répond à cette
nécessité il est le volet législatif
d'un grand plan énergie renouvelable que
je déploie depuis le mois de juin sur le
volet réglementaire avec une série de
décret prix délété et sur le plan
organisationnel avec une circulaire à
destination des préfets et le
renforcement des effectifs des services
de l'État qui a instruisent les
procédures d'autorisation dans le budget
en cours d'examen à l'Assemblée
nationale ces mesures ont déjà permis de
débloquer 10 gigawatts d'énergie
électrique et 1 terawatts de gaz
renouvelable et quand je dis toutes les
filières renouvelables je vais être très
clair je parle aussi bien de la
géothermie qui fera l'objet d'un plan
annoncé dans les prochaines semaines que
du biogaz de l'hydraulique de la
biomasse ou du photovoltaïque thermique
et vous pourrez continuer à égrainer les
sujets tous ne sont pas niveau
législatif c'est le simple constat que
je fais avant de rentrer dans le détail
de ce texte permettez-moi d'abord de
vous remercier collectivement pour les
nombreux échanges que nous avons eu
depuis la rentrée et pour le travail
préparatoire qui sera j'en suis sûr
précieux pour la suite de nos débats je
remercie particulièrement les et les
quatre rapports Aude Lucky pierre
Cazeneuve
je les cherche des yeux en commission
développement durable et Henri Alfandari
et Eric Bothorel en commission à faire
économique qui ont mené de très
nombreuses auditions qui permettront
d'enrichir le texte et les présidents
des deux commissions Jean-Marc sulezy et
Guillaume casbariian dont je sais
l'engagement sur ces questions
énergétiques je remercie aussi la
mission transpartizane d'avoir été menée
d'avoir mené des auditions et d'avoir
rendu des conclusions
ce texte vise donc à court terme à lever
les verrous administratifs et de
procédures pour diviser par deux le
délai de déploiement des projets de
production d'énergie bas carbone la
France est le seul pays de l'Union
européenne ne pas avoir atteint son
objectif national contraignant de
développement des énergies renouvelables
au titre de l'année 2020 ce qui veut
dire que pas besoin d'atteindre
d'attendre pardon la prochaine la
programmation plus réelle de l'énergie
pour savoir qu'il nous faut plus de
renouvelables ce texte porte un double
objectif celui de rattraper notre retard
et celui de nous permettre d'atteindre
un objectif plus grand qui sera très
prochainement défini dans la loi de
programmation énergique climat vous le
savez à l'heure actuelle il faut en
moyenne 50 procédures pour construire un
parc solaire qui nécessite à peine
quelques mois de travaux et plus d'une
décennie pour un parc éolien en mer
c'est à peu près deux fois plus long que
chez nos principaux voisins européens
nous proposons donc d'agir sur quatre
leviers le premier levier c'est
l'accélération des procédures par
exemple en prévoyant un raccordement en
réseau sans attendre que le projet soit
achevé pour entamer les démarches cela
permet de faire gagner une à plusieurs
années de procédure le deuxième levier
c'est de libérer le foncier en
mobilisant en priorité des terrains déjà
artificialisés au dégradés parking
friche ancienne décharge carrière site
polluée bordure d'autoroute etc ces
mesures vont permettre de libérer des
espaces et de doubler notre puissance
solaire actuelle elle s'inscrit
pleinement de l'objectif d'avoir le
moins d'impact possible sur la
biodiversité c'est pourquoi le
gouvernement donnera un avis favorable à
l'ensemble des amendements portés par
les groupes Renaissance modem
socialistes les républicains et la
France insoumise visant à favoriser
l'implantation de panneaux
photovoltaïques aux apports des voies
ferrées que nous travaillerons sur un
amendement porté par Dominique Pottier
sur les abords des voiesfléviales mais
qui n'est pas encore totalement finalisé
je souhaite que nous allions plus loin
dans ce texte et je sais que vous
travaillez déjà des propositions pour
répondre à cette impératif de concilier
le développement de projet de production
d'énergie sur notre territoire avec la
protection de la biodiversité là encore
le gouvernement donne un avis favorable
aux amendements portés par les groupes
Renaissance socialistes et écologistes
qui visent à prendre en compte les aires
marines protégées dans l'élaboration de
la cartographie des zones prioritaires
ou propices à l'implantation de projet
ou le lien en mer le troisième levier
c'est de beaucoup mieux concerter en
permettant en particulier pour les
projets en mer un débat mutualisé sur
chaque façade maritime avec l'ensemble
des parties prenantes pour décider avec
les territoires et leurs habitants du
partage de l'espace maritime dans une
grande concertation plutôt que de
multiplier de saucissonner oserais-je
les discussions sur chaque produit le
quatrième et dernier levier c'est
l'acceptabilité et l'appropriation des
projets d'énergie renouvelables pour
parler français c'est l'essentiel qu'à
reprendre en main notre destin
énergétique implique d'avoir des
infrastructures de production
énergétique près de chez soi et pas à
l'autre bout du monde
cette meilleure acceptabilité pourra
passer par un meilleur partage de la
valeur des énergies renouvelables dont
je rappelle qu'elles sont aujourd'hui
hautement compétitives ils vont
d'ailleurs générer près de 31 milliards
d'euros dans les caisses de l'État en
2022 et 2023 la discussion au Sénat a
permis de créer deux faux fléchés vers
les collectivités et vers le financement
d'action protection de la biodiversité
je salue cet enrichissement mais je
crois que nous ne devons pas oublier les
riverains de ces projets SI pourquoi
afin d'avoir une accroche pour la
discussion je porterai un amendement
gouvernement portera un amendement pour
réintroduire la possibilité aux
riverains de bénéficier directement de
ce partage de la valeur ce programme
d'accélération des énergies
renouvelables j'entends mener en prenant
en compte deux impératifs essentiels la
préservation de la biodiversité et
l'association des territoires accélérer
ne veut ni dire rabaisser les standards
de protection de notre biodiversité ni
outrepasser les territoires qui seront
des partenaires essentiels pour réarmer
notre pays énergétiquement nous posons
les fondations d'impact territorial
énergétique associé les territoires ces
planifié comme vous le savez le texte
issu du Sénat écrit deux dispositions
sur la planification l'une à l'article
premier 1A et l'autre à l'article 3 si
de nombreuses associations d'élus locaux
nous ont confirmé que cette démarche
allait dans le bon sens elles ont
néanmoins souligné la nécessité de
travailler la clarté la lisibilité du
texte sur ce sujet essentiel c'est la
raison pour laquelle on accord avec les
rapporteurs il vous sera proposé
d'harmoniser la rédaction de ces
dispositions à l'article 3 et d'avoir un
seul article qui porte la planification
je pense que c'est plus facile à
travailler derrière cela impliquera donc
la suppression de l'article premier a au
profit d'un amendement du Gouvernement
déposé à l'article 3 vous avez d'ores et
déjà la possibilité de le sous-amender
mais il me semble essentiel que nous
ayons une disposition claire et
identifiée dans le texte en vue de la
séance publique cet amendement à
l'article 3 défend plusieurs principes
donner aux élus locaux en pouvoir
d'aménagement du territoire en
définissant des zones prioritaires
inscrites dans les documents
urbanisme inciter le déploiement des
projets d'énergie renouvelables par des
porteurs de projets dans ces zones
l'État le fera grâce à la bonification
dans le cadre des appels à projets et le
gouvernement donnera un avis favorable
sous amendement porté par les
écologistes et les socialistes sur la
modulation tarifaire afin de mieux
répartir les projets sur notre
territoire et éviter leur concentration
sur certains territoires ce sont souvent
d'ailleurs les plus modestes en termes
de revenus et de coups du fonciers qui
concentrent les installations pour
pouvoir faire en sorte que tous les
territoires puissent installer des
énergies renouvelables enfin c'est un
engagement que je renouvelle faire
confiance aux maires c'est leur
permettre d'avoir le dernier mot ils
auront à cet égard un avis conforme sur
les zones prioritaires qui comprennent
leur commune les dispositions de la loi
3DS leur donnent par ailleurs la
possibilité de définir des zones
d'encadrement pour les projets éoliens
nous les tendons à l'ensemble des
projets ENR avant de conclure il me
semble important d'avoir un mot sur
l'article 4 qui porte le principe de la
reconnaissance de la raison
impérative d'intérêt publique majeur des
projets d'énergie renouvelables je sais
qu'elle soulève des craintes et surtout
peut-être des incompréhensions certains
pour des raisons de protection de la
biodiversité d'autres parce qu'ils sont
moins convaincus de la période nécessité
de développer des projets d'énergie
renouvelables pour notre avenir
énergétique cette mesure je le rappelle
est aussi actuellement portée au niveau
européen dans les discussions sur la
révision de la directive énergie
renouvelable red 3 elle vise à mettre
fin à une pratique courante et
systématique de recours contre les
projets ce recours ont pour effet de
retarder parfois de plusieurs années des
projets alors que très peu aboutissent
une fine et donc il ne s'agit en rien de
permettre des projets au détriment de la
biodiversité puisque il faut remplir des
conditions au regard de la biodiversité
pour pouvoir avancer sur les projets
donc en aucune façon la biodiversité est
mise en cause
et ils n'ont plus que l'obligation de
protection stricte des espèces protégées
ce qui est recherché ici c'est de
reconnaître tout simplement que la que
les énergies renouvelables sont bien des
projets d'intérêt public majeurs et il
me semble que le moment la cop27 la
crise climatique la crise énergétique
peut difficilement nous faire prétendre
le contraire nous ne manquerons pas de
débattre de ces sujets mais je le dis
d'office comme au Sénat le gouvernement
aura une ligne rouge il s'opposera à
toutes les mesures qui visent à
complexifier ou rallonger les procédures
voir aller bloquer
c'est une question de responsabilité
face aux Français car il s'agit bien de
voter une loi qui renforce notre
indépendance énergétique qui renforce le
pouvoir d'achat des Français qui
renforce la compétitivité de nos
entreprises et qui participent au de la
lutte contre le dérèglement climatique
je vous remercie
merci beaucoup madame la ministre je
vous propose de passer à l'écoute de nos
rapporteurs on va commencer par monsieur
Éric Bothorel pour 5 minutes
Messieurs les Présidents madame la
ministre Mesdames et Messieurs les
rapporteurs mes chers collègues nous
examinons cette semaine le projet de loi
relatif à la production d'énergie
renouvelable sur lequel j'ai plaisir
d'être rapporteur en binôme avec mon
collègue Henri alfandary au nom de la
commission des affaires économiques je
veux le remercier pour notre travail
conjoint mené durant les auditions ainsi
que l'ensemble des collègues
collaborateurs administrateurs et
administratrice qui travaille sur ce
texte je veux également remercier les
différentes personnes entendues la
semaine passée et qui ont contribué par
écrit à notre réflexion de la FNSEA
enedis en passant par sciepard et les
jeunes agriculteurs nous examinons un
texte que le Sénat considérablement
enrichi vous l'avez rappelé Madame le
Ministre et je salue la qualité du
travail accompli par nos collègues
sénateurs certaines des mesures ajoutées
vont dans le bon dans le sens du texte
comme la simplification des procédures
ou la volonté de couvrir un maximum
d'énergie renouvelables dans les
dispositifs proposés il y en a d'autres
qui ne nous satisfont pas et sur
lesquels nous proposons des évolutions
nous devons accélérer notre transition
énergétique car l’urgence climatique
n'attend pas la France doit devenir une
puissance écologique et souveraine la
transition énergétique va permettre la
création d'emplois l'émergence du
filière dernier et en même temps la
réindustrialisation en fournissant une
énergie massive et décarbonée c'est tout
le sens de notre stratégie de
décarbonation du mix énergétique Francis
français qui devra se faire avec la
population et qui tient en trois mots
sobriété nucléaire renouvelable ce
triptyque est indispensable pour sortir
de notre dépendance aux énergies
fossiles et atteindre la neutralité
carbone en 2050 conformément nos
engagements européens en matière
d'énergie renouvelable le constat est
simple la France est en retard sur ses
objectifs il nous faut rattraper ce
retard en divisant par deux les délais
entre la décision et la mise en service
des installations de production
d'énergie renouvelables les ENS en se
mérite de pouvoir être déployés
rapidement je sais que nous allons être
critiqué sur le calendrier de
présentation des projets de loi relatifs
à l'énergie certains devraient tant que
ce texte sur les énergies renouvelables
puis celui sur nucléaire soit examinés
avant les discussions sur la loi
quinquennale de la programmation
énergétique je les entends mais il me
semble que nous devons dès maintenant
faire le maximum pour accélérer le
déploiement des énerves il ne s'agit
bien sûr pas de couvrir le territoire
d'éoliennes et de panneaux solaires de
manière anarchique mais de mettre en
place une planification dans le cadre
d'une concertation étroite avec les élus
et les acteurs de terrain conduit à
l'échelle des territoires et c'est là
tout le travail de mon collègue Henri
alfanari j'en viens à présent aux
articles que je rapporte la 36 donc je
n'irai pas dans le détail de chacun
d'entre eux l'idée principale et qu'il
faut mobiliser tous les leviers
d'accélération disponibles que ce soit
au travers des procédures simplifiées de
nouveaux sites d'implantation ou de
nouveaux leviers financiers s'agissant
des mesures permettant de libérer du
foncier je suis très en particulier les
articles 9 et 10 qui ouvrent des
dérogations au principe d'implantation
en continuité urbaine dans les zones
littorales et de montagne les
dispositifs sont bien encadrés tout en
permettant à ces territoires de
s'inscrire activement dans la transition
énergétique l'article 16 facilite
également l'implantation d'ouvrage de
transport d'électricité en zone littoral
tout en préservant les espaces les plus
fra
sur la question de la rivoltaïsme le CNA
a permis d'avancer en proposant une
définition perfectible je suis ouvert à
vos propositions et nous aurons sans
doute à retravailler cette partie pour
la séance une définition claire
permettra nos agriculteurs de se saisir
de ce nouvel outil au service de
l'agriculture sans que les panneaux ne
remplacent les troupeaux et que la
production d'électricité ne vienne
mettre la pression sur la production ou
l'emploi agricole et j'y serai
particulièrement attentif l'article 17
permet de favoriser la conclusion de PPA
c'est-à-dire contrat direct entre
producteurs d'énergie renouvelables et
consommateurs qui sécurise
l'investisseurs et apportent de la
visibilité à l'acheteur le Sénat a
ouvert aux collectivités la possibilité
de souscrire les PPA et je pense que
c'est un ajout bienvenu l'article 18
porte quant à lui sur la partage de la
valeur c'est un sujet complexe afin
d'améliorer l'acceptabilité des
installations de nerf de NR
indispensable à notre souveraineté et
notre pouvoir d'achat nous souhaitons
qu'un lien soit créé entre les
installations et le bénéfice qu'elle
procure le Sénat souhaitait recentrer le
bénéfice de ce partage de la valeur sur
projet collectivités territoriales ma
volonté sur ce point est de créer un
mécanisme opérationnel qui ne crée pas
d'effet de seuil ou de rupture d'égalité
entre les citoyens je ne doute pas que
notre travail commun permettra de
trouver un chemin enfin je me réjouis de
débats à venir donc j'ai nul doute qui
nous permettront de tendre vers un
objectif partagé
déployé davantage d'énergie renouvelable
plus vite et dans le respect de nos
territoires car il nous faut croire et
agir pour des choses qui ont des chances
de se réaliser affronter ensemble les
problèmes et se mettre d'accord sur les
modalités certains auront reconnu ici
une dernière citation de Jean-Marc
Jancovici dans son dernier ouvrage je
suis convaincu que cette méthode de
dialogue et l'esprit de compromis à
l'oeuvre Sénat seront également
prévaloires dans notre assemblée je vous
remercie
merci beaucoup monsieur le rapporteur
Michel fondari c'est à vous
merci Messieurs les Présidents madame la
ministre Madame et Monsieur les
rapporteurs chers collègues
je veux vous partager ma satisfaction de
commencer aujourd'hui l'examen de la loi
d'accélération des énergies
renouvelables à l'Assemblée nationale et
mon plaisir de travailler avec mes
collègues au Luquet pierre Cazeneuve et
Eric bottorel en cet instant je souhaite
saluer le travail déjà effectué par nos
collègues sénateurs ils enrichi le texte
l'ont structuré et cela va nous
permettre de l'améliorer à notre tour
pour dégager le bon chemin entre la part
législative et la part opérationnelle je
tiens également à remercier avant toute
chose madame la ministre en espagnol une
hachée d'avoir proposé une première
étape du dispositif d'accélération qui
part des mers n'oublions pas qu'ils sont
le socle de la République et que chaque
pouvoir qu'il aurait attribué pour
servir nos concitoyens nous renforce
tous dans nos prorogatives il est donc
salutaire que les mers constituent le
départ de nos actions de planification
d'autant plus que c'est eux qui sont en
première ligne pour l'exceptabilité des
citoyennes des projets
nous devons ces premières prochaines
semaines trouver un mécanisme juste qui
permet de rassurer autant nos élus que
nos concitoyens pour permettre une
meilleure anticipation des projets et
favoriser une méthode de planification
permettant les projets et les synergies
locales
pour un souci de clarté l'ensemble du
dispositif de planification se développe
dans l'article 3 de cette loi
l'amendement déposé à la suite de la
suppression du titre 1a reprend
plusieurs apports du travail des
sénateurs et ouvre également des
éléments solides de déploiement des
énergies renouvelables il nous reste
cependant à faire du travail à faire
pour mieux anticiper le code de articulé
le code de l'énergie et le code de
l'urbanisme pour trouver la balance
entre la nécessaire liberté qui doit
être laissée aux élus locaux dans le
choix opérationnel de ces énergies et la
réalisation des objectifs nationaux
soient aussi entre une obligation de
moyens et une obligation de résultats
pour définir une ligne de partage entre
l'accélération qui nécessite de limiter
les risques de contentieux et de recours
et la préservation de l'environnement et
des paysages qui se doit de respecter
nos règles et l'expression des citoyens
pour imaginer aussi une véritable
récompense qui lit territoire urbain et
territoire ruraux dans le portage de cet
effort nécessaire à tous la ligne est
ardue dans certains points peuvent
sembler contradictoires cependant nous
avons une chance d'arriver à concilier
ces exigences et à réaliser nos
objectifs cette chance c'est la
planification
c'est elle qui permet par l'effet du
temps de positionner la bonne action ou
justement je suis honoré et impatient en
tant que rapporteur accompagné par les
précieuses des administrateurs que nous
réalisions ensemble députés gouvernement
ce travail de planification à partir
d'aujourd'hui
merci beaucoup monsieur le rapporteur
nous allons passer au rapporteur de la
commission Développement Durable
monsieur le Président vous souhaitez les
annoncer
la parole est donc à Pierre Cazeneuve
merci monsieur le Président Madame la
Ministre messieurs les présidents de
commission madame et Messieurs les cours
à porteurs mes chers collègues la lutte
contre les multiples crises écologiques
est incontestablement le défi de notre
siècle parmi elles ne dérèglement
alarmant du climat qui pourrait s'avérer
deux fois plus intense que prévu en
France selon le CNRS
il n'est plus seulement question de
léguer une planète habitable au futur
générations il s'agit bien d'assumer le
maintien de conditions vivables à court
terme pour de nombreuses régions du
globe y compris la nôtre la guerre en
Ukraine quant à elle nous rappelle
brutalement la subordination de notre
société aux énergies fossiles importées
au dérèglement climatique s'ajoute donc
une crise énergétique sans précédent
depuis les années 1970
pour rappel aujourd'hui encore 65% de
notre consommation énergétique est liée
au fossiles et donc constitue une
extraordinaire dépendance
vous l'aurez compris il y a donc deux
objectifs afférents à ce projet de loi
regagnant souveraineté et lutter contre
le dérèglement climatique et je suis
certain que tous ici quel que soit les
bancs nous partageons ces deux objectifs
l'urgence est bien là mais nous
disposons de solutions la première c'est
la sobriété si elle n'est pas l'objet de
ce projet de loi en tant que tel je me
dois de la mentionner car sans elle
notre partition ne pourra être mise en
musique l'autre priorité réside dans le
déploiement massif de la production
d'énergie décarbonée certains je le sais
seront tentés de tout ramener au
nucléaire je leur dis trois choses la
première soyons patients nous aurons
prochainement à discuter et nous aurons
ce débat dans notre assemblée très très
prochainement la seconde c'est que vous
pourrez trouver vous trouverez toujours
chez moi un grand défenseur de l'atome
mais que je suis persuadé que sur ce
sujet comme sur tant d'autres la bonne
réponse est toujours dans l'équilibre en
regardant scientifiquement et
rationnellement la situation et les
chiffres
la troisième c'est que quand tu as
débuté la construction de l'EPR de
Flamanville en 2006 j'avais 11 ans quoi
que l'on puisse dire aux pensées il
faudra pour construire ses réacteurs
énormément de temps or nous avons besoin
aujourd'hui de pouvoir augmenter nos
capacités de production c'est de cela
dont parle ce texte de produire
massivement et immédiatement des
nouvelles énergies des carbonées et si
scénarios émis par RTE dans son rapport
futur énergétique 2050 tous détiennent
par significatif d'énergie renouvelable
il faut être clair quel que soit notre
position sur le sujet nous n'avons pas
le choix dans toutes les configurations
la marge demeure très haute moins de 30
ans nous séparent du bilan de cette
révolution énergétique et nous peinons
déjà à atteindre nos objectifs en effet
les énergies renouvelables représentées
19,3% de notre consommation finale brute
énergétique alors que nous étions
engagés à attendre 23%
actuellement il faut compter 50
procédures pour un parc solaire 7 ans
pour un parc éolien terrestre et plus
d'une décennie pour un parc éolien en
mer c'est deux fois plus long que c'est
la plupart de nos voisins européens ce
texte doit donc nous permettre de
rattraper nos retard sur nos objectifs
de déploiement avec quatre grands axes
le premier c'est planifier le
déploiement de ces énergies
renouvelables dans nos territoires en
partant des communes ainsi que la
planification de nos façades maritimes
le second c'est accélérer et
rationaliser les procédures
administratives là où les adaptations
sont pertinentes tout en préservant la
biodiversité et la nécessaire
participation du public le troisième
c'est libérer le foncier en ciblant en
priorité les zones déjà artificialisées
et notamment les parkings les friches ou
les bordures d'autoroute tout en
encadrant les nouvelles activités et
enfin la quatrième développer le partage
territorial de la valeur avec les
collectivités locales les entreprises et
les citoyens je le dis avec beaucoup de
force au-delà de l'enjeu d'accélération
et de rationalisation
ce projet de loi doit respecter deux
grands principes la protection de la
biodiversité car si le changement
climatique est l'une des premières
causes de l'érosion de la biodiversité
cette même érosion nourrit l'emballement
climatique et donc primordial d'avoir
une approche très cohérente des futurs
projets qui sortiront de terre le second
c'est la concertation et la
co-construction l'effectivité des
mesures que nous adopterons ces
prochains jours dépendra de leur
application et de leur appropriation à
l'échelle territoriale et du local
depuis bientôt 10 ans je sais
l'important c'est la nécessité de faire
confiance à nos élus qui connaissent
mieux que quiconque leur commune et
partage notre ambition de mener à bien
cette transition
il s'agit d'un enrichissement par
ailleurs apporté lors de l'examen du
Sénat et je souhaite saluer cette
avancée et d'autres évolutions votées
qui vont à mes yeux dans le bon sens
sur le volet de planification notamment
comme il était indiqué par Madame la
Ministre et précisé à l'ensemble des
groupes nous allons donc concentré cette
discussion sur l'article 3 qui serait
étudié dans la commission des affaires
économiques mais nous aurons bien sûr le
débat ce soir en ddat sur ce même sujet
aussi je l'espère les avis que j'ai
mettrai dans les prochains jours dans
cette commission commencer en public
seront guidées le plus possible par cet
enjeu de rationalisation et
l'amélioration lorsque et l'amélioration
de ce texte lorsque cela est pertinent
dans un esprit de concertation et de
dialogue pour finir je souhaite saluer
mes collègues qu'on rapporteurs et
notamment au deluquier madame la
ministre ainsi que l'ensemble des
responsables de textes pour l'ensemble
de ces lois merci beaucoup
[Musique]
merci chers collègues la parole est à
haut du quai
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Président de la commission des affaires
économiques madame la ministre mes chers
courant porteurs Mesdames et Messieurs
chers collègues
mon intervention portera sur le titre de
du projet de loi qui vise plus
particulièrement accélérer le
développement de l'énergie solaire
mais sans reprendre les propos
liminaires à la fois de Madame la
Ministre et des précédents orateurs je
souhaiterais rappeler je souhaiterais
les motivations qui ont guidé ce texte
notre façon de produire et consommer de
l'énergie et non seulement une question
environnementale mais aussi de
souveraineté cela est déjà été dit nous
défaire des énergies fossiles fossiles
c'est agir pour le climat et
l'environnement en plus de réduire notre
dépendance à des pays tiers lagenda
France 2030 ou encore le plan de
sobriété trace ce cap aujourd'hui si
notre production d'électricité est
décarbonée à plus de 90%, notre
consommation d'énergie dépend encore
majoritairement des énergies fossiles
pétrole et gaz en tête dans notre mix
énergétique le solaire ne représente
qu'un peu plus de 2% de notre production
d'électricité contre 8% en Italie ou 7%
en Allemagne en RTE a été clair dans son
récent en rapport neutralité carbone en
2050 passe par plus d'énergie
renouvelables en complément de notre
part nucléaire
concernant le solaire les objectifs sont
ambitieux avec la volonté de multiplié
par 10 notre puissance voltaï
on nous l'avons dit les uns et les
autres le temps presse aujourd'hui il
faut en moyenne 50 procédures pour
construire un parc solaire alors même
que celui-ci ne nécessite que quelques
mois de travaux il nous faut aller deux
fois plus vite cela ne veut pas dire
forcer la main mais mieux identifier les
espaces propices aux énergies
renouvelables à travers une véritable
planification territoriale il s'agit
également privilégier ce qui est du
soleil des espaces déjà urbanisés en
optimis en optimisant le bâti existant
et d'engager un meilleur partage de la
valeur avec les communes
en activant l'ensemble de ces leviers
que nous parviendrons à favoriser
l'acceptabilité des projets les moins
indispensables pour accélérer le
développement des énergies renouvelables
dans notre pays j'en viens maintenant
aux articles pour lesquels je suis
rapporteur tout d'abord l'article 7 qui
rend possible l'installation
d'infrastructures de production
d'énergie solaire non des grands axes
routiers et voies ferrées c'est une
véritable avancée car aujourd'hui seul
les délaissés routiers les aires de
repos de service et de stationnement
peuvent accueillir de telles
installations et sénateurs sont allés
plus loin en incluant les voies ferrées
c'est un ajout positives que je salue
ensuite l'article 11 propose la création
d'une obligation d'équipement des parcs
de stationnement extérieures par des
ombrières intégrant un procédé dernière
RG renouvelable alors que les textes
d'origine prévoyaient que cette
obligation s'appliquait au parking de
plus de 2500 mètres carrés les sénateux
en substient une logique en substituées
par nos logiques de nombre
d'emplacements en retenant le seuil de
80 places et en excluant les parkings
poids lourds du dispositif je vous
proposerai de réintégrer ces derniers de
revenir à une notion de surface pour
faciliter l'application de et le
contrôle du dispositif nous avons
ensuite des articles 11 bis on se taire
11 octets qui ont le point l'ambition de
favoriser l'installation de production
d'énergie solaire sur la couverture du
bâti existant sur ces articles ma
position éclair nous avons voté en 2021
dans la loi climère résilience un
certain nombre de dispositions et il me
semble qu'il n'y a pas pire que de
changer des règles chaque année alors
même que de telles transitions demande
un cadre clair et stable sur le temps
long face aux investissements que cela
représente je serai donc majoritairement
favorable aux amendements qui permettent
de revenir à ce que nous avions voté
dans la loi climat et résilience nous
avons ensuite l'article 11 squatters qui
permet aux travaux d'installation de
panneaux solaires pour de
l'autoconsommation d'être éligible à les
couper TZ de nombreux dispositifs de
soutien existent déjà je soutiendrai
donc une suppression de cet article
enfin nous avons les articles 11 non
nièces et 11 des siestes qui lit des
orientages par nos remplacements des
toitures
concernées par des panneaux voltaïques
je pense que ce sujet demande des études
approfondies et pour terminer les
articles 11 des six SB et 11 dcies C
vise c'est la prise en compte des
critères environnementaux dans la
commande publique et dans la procédure
d'attribution d'appel d'offres émis par
la creux ces deux ajouts du Sénat vont
dans le bon sens et je vous proposerai
de les garder tout en fusionnant ces
deux articles pour plus de cartes pour
conclure je regarde le temps qui m'est
imparti je suis encore dans le temps je
tiens à saluer
tout le travail qui a été fait notamment
avec Monsieur Cazeneuve mon cours à
porteur et a souhaité que nous ayons des
états riches apaisés mais qui nous
permettent d'avancer collectivement vers
un futur plus de rap je vous remercie
merci beaucoup madame la rapporteur je
vous propose de passer donc au
orateurs de groupe comme je vous le
disais tout à l'heure c'est 4 minutes de
prise de parole par orateur inclut la
réponse de la ministre vous avez la
possibilité de parler jusqu'à 3 minutes
maximum et laisser une minute minimum de
réponse à madame la ministre vous pouvez
aussi faire le choix de faire des
questions courtes réponse courte et
enchaîner dans une discussion de 4
minutes et donc voilà le process que je
vous propose madame bateau oui allez-y
pardon monsieur le Président c'est juste
sur le déroulement des travaux vous
semblez préconisez une organisation
comparable à celle des auditions mais on
est dans un dans un débat soit un projet
de loi donc je suis pas sûr que sur
chaque intervention une réponse du
gouvernement soit nécessaire bien sûr
l'alternative qui était pour alors on a
vu avec l'ensemble des groupes et
Thierry côté administrateur à transmis
l'information l'alternative sinon
c'était de faire deux minutes de prise
parrole par orateur de groupe et de les
prendre tous à la chaîne on a préféré
vous donner plus de temps donc vous
pouvez aller jusqu'à 3 minutes de prise
de parole en laissant une minute de
réponse à la ministre mais sinon
l'alternative c'est de faire deux
minutes de prise par le par orateur de
groupe mais ça vous laisse moins de
temps pour interroger donc donc je vous
propose de continuer ainsi c'est comme
ça qu'on a convenu madame bateau et on
l'a fait pour pour tous les sujets
jusqu'à présent
et donc je vous propose de commencer
tout de suite madame Laurence Mayer mais
pour le groupe Renaissance c'était à
vous
merci monsieur le président
[Musique]
madame la ministre
mais Président Mesdames et Messieurs les
rapporteurs mes chers collègues alors
moi j'avais pas le temps
mais je vais faire court entre minutes
et aller à l'essentiel pour vous dire
que ce projet de loi il est important il
est même stratégies la France et
l'Europe ont pris des engagements
ambitieux dans moins de 30 ans l'Union
européenne devra atteindre la neutralité
carbone or vous l'avez rappelé madame la
ministre notre mix énergétique est
aujourd'hui encore majoritairement
carbonée et notre consommation finale
dépend à 65% des énergies fossiles
produites par des puissances étrangères
le défi est immense et notre cap est
clair nous devons part de la les clivage
politique reprendront en main notre
destin énergétique pour atteindre la
neutralité carbone en 2050 et faire de
la France le premier grand pays
industriel assortir des énergies
fossiles alors c'est tout l'enjeu de ce
projet de loi que nous allons enrichir
ensemble pour donner un coup
d'accélérateur au déploiement de toutes
les énergies renouvelables solaires et
aux liens géothermiques hydrauliques
biomasse ce texte doit nous permettre de
simplifier les procédures améliorer
l'acceptabilité et projet par les
citoyens mieux impliquer les élus locaux
mieux planifier et permettre un meilleur
partage de la valeur je ne rentrerai pas
dans le détail de ces mesures les
rapporteurs l'ont très bien fait je
voulais dire aussi que nous avons à
salué le travail des sénateurs qui ont
apporté en première lecture du projet de
loi des enrichissements d'une
cinquantaine d'articles avec de nombreux
consensus qui témoignent malgré nos
différences de notre volonté collective
d'aller dans le même sens et je ne doute
pas que nous aurons dans nos deux
commissions des on change tout aussi
exigeant à la hauteur des enjeux je vous
remercie
[Musique]
c'est bon très bien
pour le groupe rassemblement national la
parole est à Pierre mein
merci Messieurs les Présidents madame la
ministre Mesdames et Messieurs les
rapporteurs chers collègues la crise
énergétique que nous vivons est le
résultat non pas de facteurs externes
par lesquels vous tentez
systématiquement de vous justifier mais
bien de cause structurelles de choix
politiques inconséquents et de passivité
dans la guerre économique que nous mène
depuis son étrangères et en particulier
l'Allemagne
en fermant la centrale de Fessenheim
tout en rouvrent des centrales à charbon
vous alignez notre politique énergétique
sur l'Allemagne qui émet pour rappel 500
g de CO2 par kWh d'électricité produite
soit 10 fois plus que la France
notre stratégie énergétique devrait
faire l'objet d'un texte unique global
et avec une trajectoire claire sur
l'ensemble du mix énergétique français
en incorporant tous les modes de
production y compris le nucléaire ce
texte est donc un acte manqué pour
débattre de l'ensemble de notre avenir
énergétique
concernant les éoliennes
la France dispose d'une électricité
décarbonée à 92% grâce au nucléaire
pilotable et la moins chère d'Europe
alors que pour produire l'équivalent de
la centrale du budget soit 4 réacteurs
avec une emprise au sol de 1 km², il
faudrait construire les chiffres sont
fous 447 éoliennes sur une emprise au
sol de 506 km². alors qu'une éolienne
nécessite un socle de 1300 tonnes de
béton l'exploitation de terre rare
notamment en Chine dont les dont les
effluents pardon rendent toxiques les
eaux alors que les éoliennes nécessitent
aussi l'exploitation massive de balsa en
Amazonie contribuant à la déforestation
du poumon de la planète ce qui semble
laisser indifférent nos collègues de
gauche vos énergies dites renouvelables
sont des énergies intermittentes qui
nous rendent dépendant de la météo en
plus d'être dépendant d'autres pays
j'ajoute qu'en permettant que ces
installations soient couvertes par la
raison d'intérêts publiques majeurs et
contrairement à vos propos rassurants
madame la ministre vous faites fille de
toutes les mises en garde en matière de
protection de la biodiversité là encore
dans l'indifférence des écologistes je
formule un dernier appel sur ce point
les promoteurs éoliens en France sont à
65 % allemand et 30 % danois où est la
filière française votre texte en faveur
des promoteurs et des maîtres d'ouvrage
contient une parodie de consultation du
public des dérogations majeures à la
protection de la nature l'achat du
silence des riverains avec l'argent du
contribuable et l'absence de garde-fou
pour les élus locaux je souhaite dire
aux républicains que nous accueillons
avec intérêt les déclarations du
président Marleix qui se dit prêt à s'y
opposer nous espérons pouvoir faire
cause commune pendant les débats en
l'état évidemment nous allons nous
opposer à ce texte le groupe
rassemblement national proposera des
amendements qui permettront de rétablir
des garde-fous juridiques comme par
exemple la vie conforme des élus locaux
nous serons également constructifs en
faisant des propositions en commission
et sur l'ensemble des modes de
production énergétique qui font
consensus et notamment l'hydrogène la
géothermie et l'hydroélectricité je vous
remercie
merci chers collègues madame la ministre
je vous laisse le soin de répondre
j'ai pas la micro ok première chose nous
la crise elle est aussi liée à un choc
externe sur l'énergie quand 40% de
l'approvisionnement d'un continent est
issu d'un seul pays pour le gaz naturel
de fait ça fait un choc externe je me
permets de vous renvoyer vers la
situation d'autres pays qui sont
confrontés très exactement la même
situation et de tension sur la
production de leur énergie de leur gaz
et de leur électricité donc ce que vous
dites est faux c'est un texte sur les
énergies renouvelables c'est pas un
texte sur les éoliennes terrestres
d'ailleurs à aucun moment dans ce texte
pardon de le souligner en tout cas dans
la proposition qui avait déposé le
gouvernement au Sénat il y avait le
terme éoliennes terrestre les éoliennes
les énergies renouvelables c'est le
photovoltaïques c'est aussi la biomasse
c'est aussi le biogaz c'est
la géothermie toutes ces technologies
profitent bénéficient des titres et en
particulier du Titre 1 sur euh les
procédures j'aurais aimé vous entendre
sur cela il n'y a pas de dérogation
majeure à la biodiversité merci beaucoup
tout à l'heure vous aurez l'occasion de
répondre aux autres interpellations
merci madame la ministre monsieur l'aîné
pour le groupe la France insoumise
merci monsieur le Président Madame et
Monsieur les rapporteurs madame la
ministre mes chers collègues la France
accuse un retard important en matière de
déploiement des énergies renouvelables
par rapport aux objectifs fixés à
l'horizon 2030 si nous partageons la
volonté d'accélérer évidemment nous
sommes dubitatif tant sur la méthode que
sur les dispositions concrètes de ce
projet de loi sur la méthode celui-ci
s'inscrit dans un contexte immédiat de
risque sur la sécurité
d'approvisionnement et dans des enjeux
de long terme de sobriété et
d'efficacité énergétique que la loi doit
traiter et pas seulement un catalogue
sur la sobriété qui a été proposé à
prendre ou à laisser au mois d'octobre
nous abordons ainsi au printemps la
refonte de la programmation pluralienne
de l'énergie en lien avec les scénarios
proposés par RTE par l'ADEM et Negawatt
qui propose entre autres des scénarios à
100% renouvelables scénario que nous
soutenons il nous semble ainsi que l'on
prend les choses dans le désordre
puisqu'on parle ici des moyens
d'accélérer avant même d'avoir fixé des
objectifs et la part de ses ENR dans le
futur mix énergétique un problème de
mystère dans les dreals pour l'autorité
environnementale ce qui n'a pas été
prévu dans le cadre du budget elle ne se
co-construira qu'à l'appui d'une
planification nationale territorialisée
démocratisée fondée sur des objectifs de
développement chiffrés mais ce débat est
envoyé à plus tard même si l'article
premier a dessiné les débuts d'une
planification maintenant renvoyer à
l'article 3 sur lequel nous demanderons
des garanties quand à nos sous
amendements c'est à ce prix que
l'acceptabilité se fera et non sur un
partage de la valeur qui est monétarise
l'intérêt général enfin votre projet de
loi se place dans la continuité d'un
marché de l'énergie libéralisée pourtant
une politique publique de l'énergie
efficace se construira en sortant du
carcan européen et en construisant une
filière publique y compris de production
ainsi plutôt que des contrats de gré à
gré nous proposons la possibilité d'un
acheteur unique de la production qui
fixerait des tarifs stables fondés sur
les coûts de production loin des
objectifs de rentabiliser de rentabilité
exigées par les mâches les marchés
pardon notre vote dépendra donc de la
qualité de nos débats et de la prise en
compte de nos propositions
merci beaucoup madame la ministre pour
une minute
très rapidement sur la planification je
le redis je pense que pour la clarté la
lisibilité du texte il faut faire un
seul article c'est ce que nous faisons
ça va permettre d'être une plateforme de
travail pour l'ensemble des députés les
objectifs ils sont connus permettent de
mettre les élus locaux au centre du jeu
de préparer et de repérer les zones les
plus aptes à recevoir des énergies
renouvelables et de le faire dans le
respect de la programmation plus réelle
de l'énergie puisque on leur
communiquera à la fois au niveau des
préfets ça c'est déjà fait des
cartographies de raccordement de zone
sensible à différents titres en termes
environnemental en termes de prévention
des risques pour faciliter cette
cartographie également des objectifs de
potentiels de production par territoire
merci madame la ministre pour le groupe
les républicains la parole est à
Emmanuel maqué
Messieurs les Présidents madame la
ministre mes chers collègues on ne peut
légiférer sur l'énergie qu'avec une main
tremblante parce que c'est elle se situe
au carrefour de 4 enjeux cruciaux pour
nos concitoyens un bien essentiel pour
la vie quotidienne carburant de
croissance pour notre économie un levier
de puissance géopolitique et enfin un
paramètre majeur de lutte contre le
réchauffement climatique ces quatre
enjeux vie quotidienne niveau de vie
souveraineté climat traverse des crises
urgentes et profondes qui nécessitent
des choix stratégiques au lieu de cela
vous proposez un test qui accumule les
mesures techniques pour poursuivre des
choix qui n'ont pas prouvé leur
efficacité actuellement la France et le
pays européen ou le risque de coupure
électrique est le plus puissant cet
hiver est-ce que ce texte atténuera ce
risque pour l'hiver 2023 2033 ou même
2043 la réponse est non actuellement les
industries énergétiques décarbonées
réside à l'étranger la filière nucléaire
a été sapée avec l'acharnement quant au
renouvelable ils sont allemands ou
chinois est-ce que ce texte permettra de
fleurons français la réponse est non
actuellement les choix énergétiques
structurants de la France sont orientés
vers des énergies dont l'intermittence
doit être compensées par le gaz est-ce
que ce texte nous rendra moins dépendant
des pays exportateurs de gaz dont nous
ne partons je prends les valeurs la
réponse est non enfin nous venons de
connaître le mois d'octobre le plus
chaud jamais enregistré depuis un été
lui-même record est-ce que ce texte
concerne un volume d'énergie suffisant
pour remplacer les plus de 1000
terawatts d'énergie fossiles que nous
consommons chaque année vous le savez la
réponse est malheureusement non la
composition du groupe les républicains
et donc claire nous souhaitons débattre
sur la stratégie avant de débattre sur
les modalités vous avez inversé la
logique en nous proposant ce texte avant
la révision de la PPE qui sera le moment
structurant pour les choix énergétiques
de la France en l'occurrence malgré
certains apports bienvenue des sénateurs
nous abordons cette discussion avec la
conviction qu'il reste encore beaucoup
de travail pour qu'il devienne
acceptable le groupe les républicains et
tout aussi attaché que vous à la lutte
contre le réchauffement climatique il
n'a d'ailleurs pas à rougir du bil dont
il assume l'héritage Premier ministère
de l'Environnement plan Messmer loi de
protection littorale Grenelle 1 et 2 en
l'état en l'état pardon le texte
franchit des lignes rouges qui nous
semblent pas négociables nous avons
besoin que la place des élus locaux soit
mieux reconnue pour l'acceptation des
projets en l'état la vie conforme sur un
simple zonage lequel n'est même pas
requis pour la validation des projets
n'est pas suffisant nous avons besoin de
mieux protéger les habitants de la
ruralité qui voient leur paysage dégradé
leurs conditions de vie atteinte sans
une augmentation des distances
d'éloignement des éoliennes à la fois
sur terre et sur mer nous ne pourrons
pas soutenir votre texte enfin notre
conception du partage de la valeur c'est
une énergie bon marché parce qu'elle a
été efficace pas grâce à un système
complexe de tarif garanti et de
rétrotaxe consommateurs qui donnent
l'illusion du Mont marché ce qui est en
réalité très onéreux tel n'est pas le
cas des énergies que vous nous proposez
d'accélérer je vous en remercie
la ministre pour un peu plus d'une
minute
alors
je vous rappelle que la France s'est
très bien positionné sur la filière des
énergies marines des éoliennes marines
c'est 6500 emplois directs à
Saint-Nazaire
au Havre et à Cherbourg
ce sont des exportations en direction
des États-Unis et du Royaume-Uni et
c'est près 80% de valeur qui reste en
France lorsqu'on fait des projets
d'éoliennes marines je vous invite à
considérer ça puisque nous avons eu
cette discussion au Sénat et le Sénat a
finalement
est revenu sur sa position initiale de
distance à cause vis-à-vis des côtes
notamment de ce fait là puisque ça
aurait été très clairement un signal non
seulement un signal mais la fin de cette
filière avec tous les emplois directs
mais également induits et je crois que
ce point-là avait bien été compris par
les maires qui accueillent ces
différentes installations sur les autres
je rappelle que le plan France 2030 est
complètement dessus voilà merci beaucoup
monsieur Milliane modem merci monsieur
le Président le monsieur le Président
Madame la Ministre Madame et Monsieur
les rapporteurs mes chers collègues la
France accuse un retard non négligeable
dans l'atteinte de ses objectifs de
développement des énergies renouvelables
à titre d'exemple en mer les 80
premières éoliennes viennent d'être
mises en place au large de Saint-Nazaire
alors que l'Europe en compte déjà 5700
sur terre l'Allemagne a installé quatre
fois plus de Mac la France alors que son
territoire est plus dense pourtant
est-ce bien nécessaire de rappeler
pourquoi ce développement massif est
indispensable cela est désormais évident
pour quiconque s'intéresse au sujet et
fait preuve d'honnêteté intellectuelle
même si nous consommerons moins
d'énergie globalement nous devrons
produire environ 60% d'électricité en
plus qu'aujourd'hui les députés du
groupe démocrate accueillent donc ce
texte avec enthousiasme est
détermination cette transition doit se
faire avec et au service de tous les
s'est passé c'est pourquoi nous nous
félicitons que ce texte propose des
procédures d'implantation plus proche
des territoires et nous saluons à cet
égard l'engagement et le sens des
responsabilités de nos collègues
sénateurs pour plus d'acceptabilité nous
devons donner aux Français les moyens
d'être acteurs c'est en ce sens que
notre groupe portera la réintégration du
dispositif de remise sur la facture
d'électricité pour les ménages concernés
par l'implantation de projet l'enjeu du
partage de la valeur et dans la DN de
notre groupe dans un autre domaine une
série de mesures liées à
l'autoconsommation ne considérer nous
considérons qu'il s'agit d'un levier
très intéressant pour que les
consommateurs se saisissent des enjeux
nous souhaitons également étendre la
portée du texte à une plus grande
diversité de sources d'énergie je pense
à l'hydroélectricité à la géothermie à
la méthanisation ou encore biogaz car
oui notre mix énergétique ne doit pas
oublier le gaz car la trajectoire
d'électrification ne fera pas
disparaître certains usages
nous souhaitent nous soutiendrons
également des mesures pour encore plus
d'accélération et de simplification en
permettant par exemple l'installation de
panneaux photovoltaïques sur les
parkings viace une simple déclaration
préalable de travaux et non plus via
l'obtention d'un permis de construire
qui peut rallonger les délais de
plusieurs mois sur ce titre nous allons
l'engagement de notre rapporteur et
collègue de Luquet qui a eu pour
boussole la complexe articulation de nos
objectifs énergétiques et
environnementaux il est rare dans la vie
parlementaire de pouvoir travailler à un
texte qui marque une inflexion non pas
sur les deux trois ou cinq prochaines
années à venir mais bien pour des
décennies ce texte est la première
pierre pour construire notre système
énergétique des prochaines décédées
comme ce fut le cas pour le nucléaire il
y a 60 ans sous le général de Gaulle
c'est non seulement une responsabilité
pour nous-mêmes pour l'avenir de nos
enfants pour le bien commun qui nous
oblige à dépasser les postures
politiques habituelles travaillant tous
ensemble ici à l'Assemblée mais aussi
dans nos circonscriptions avec les
français pour faire le texte une
réussite tant sur le plan de la méthode
que des résultats je vous remercie merci
beaucoup madame la ministre
je pense qu'on se rejoindra sur un
certain nombre d'éléments effectivement
un nous avons besoin d'appuyer
l'ensemble du registre de toutes les
énergies renouvelables c'est dans ce
sens que nous avons construit le texte
nous avons d'ailleurs interrogé tous les
opérateurs des différentes filières pour
qu'ils nous remontent des mesures on
constate que certaines remontent
tardivement et on les a prises au Sénat
il peut en avoir peut-être d'autres et
on les accueillera évidemment
positivement sur les autres sujets je
pense que on saura trouver effectivement
une ligne partagée
je vois pas de points d'écart notable et
je partage totalement la philosophie de
votre propos
merci madame la ministre pour le groupe
socialiste et apparenté la parole la
parole est à Stéphane de l'autre aide
et président madame la ministre madame
et Messieurs les rapporteurs chers
collègues le groupe socialiste est
apparenté a été particulièrement
critique du projet de loi initial une
critique sur la forme tout d'abord
puisqu'il s'agit dans des battre avant
de le faire sur la programmation
pluriannuelle de l'énergie et la SNBC et
avant que soit mené un grand débat
national sur notre stratégie énergétique
il faut il est vrai accélérer mais on ne
construit rien de durable sans commencer
par des fondations solides des critiques
ensuite sur le fond alors que ce texte
ne prévoyait aucune mesure de
planification ou de financement et
excluser excluer plusieurs énergies
comme l'hydroélectricité fort
heureusement le Sénat très largement
enrichi ce texte vous avez tendu la main
madame la ministre au groupe
d'opposition pour travailler de manière
constructive sur ce projet de loi et
nous l'avons saisi dès lors que nous
partageons l'objectif à défaut de
l'ensemble des moyens pour l'attendre
nous regrettons cependant que sur la
planification territoriale malgré nos
nombreux échanges sur le fond vous ayez
fait le choix d'une réécriture des
articles concernés sans nous en informer
lors de ces discussions mis au pied du
mur nous proposerons à minima des sous
amendements à l'article 3 pour avoir ce
débat dès lors que le traitement des
amendements sera fait dans les lois
cette planification repose pour nous sur
le bloc communes intercommunalité niveau
pertinent sur le zonage et l'impulsion
des ENR avec les scottes comme documents
d'urbanisme socle nous proposons en
outre une procédure unique intégrée de
mise en conformité et en compatibilité
des documents de rangs supérieurs et
inférieur afin d'aller vite et
d'associer et lui et citoyens ces choix
stratégiques nous vous l'avions dit lors
de nos échanges nous avons une approche
ambitieuse sur l'accélération des ENR et
proposons dans cet esprit un
renforcement des obligations en matière
de photovoltaïques en toiture sur le
neuf comme sur bien et un cadre
favorable au développement d'un éolien
mieux accepté par nos concitoyens nous
proposerons une meilleure régularisation
de la grivevoltaïsme et de la
méthanisation pour écarter les
détournements actuels nous proposerons
des mesures pour faire de nos
territoires ultramarins des territoires
outre-mer 100% ENR nous proposerons
également de faire des zones d'activités
économiques des parcs d'activités à
énergie positive enfin sur le partage
territorial de la valeur il nous
apparaît essentiel comme il y a procédé
le Sénat que se partagent se fasse à
destination des collectivités
territoriales exclusivement et au
bénéfice de fonds finançant la
transition énergétique et l'adaptation
au changement climatique nous
proposerons de compléter ces
dispositions en ce sens et nous
opposerons à tous mécanisme
individualistes à destination des
particuliers qui ne peut être que le
prélude a des conflits de voisinage à
des iniquités qui se feront au détriment
de l'accélération des projets le temps
imparti pour cette discussion générale
ne me permet hélas pas d'être plus long
mais je terminerai en précisant que mon
groupe pourra envisager de voter ce
texte dès lors que votre volonté
affichée de co-construction se traduira
dans les faits et si nous renforçons
encore l'ambition de ce texte sans
revenir sur les progrès apportés par le
Sénat
merci chers collègues madame la ministre
je voudrais revenir très vite 3 minutes
30 c'est pas moi qui ai pris les 3
minutes je voulais revenir très vite sur
la question de la PPE parce que elle est
revenue plusieurs fois je rappelle qu'on
est au milieu d'une PPE et qu'elle n'est
pas atteinte donc ce texte justifie
parfaitement dans un cadre où nous
devrions avoir 23% de notre pix
énergétique en énergie renouvelable nous
n'en avons que 19%. pour passer de 19 à
23% vous aura pas échappé que c'est un
effort de l'ordre de 25% d'augmentation
donc je peux pas entendre ici qu'on met
pas les choses dans le bon ordre alors
qu'on sait déjà qu'on a un objectif qui
n'est pas atteint et que sans avoir être
un spécialiste de l'énergie tout le
monde aura compris que l'objectif de
production d'énergie renouvelable est
appelée augmentée dans la prochaine PPE
c'est d'ailleurs ce que ce sur quoi nous
sommes d'ores et déjà engagés au niveau
de l'Union européenne donc à part être
une façon de pas vouloir regarder
l'obstacle je pense que ce n'est pas un
bon argument si je puis me permettre sur
la question et bien c'est un merci merci
beaucoup monsieur l'amirault horizon il
n'est pas
excusez-moi
madame la ministre Madame et Monsieur
les rapporteurs mes chers collègues nous
examinons aujourd'hui le projet de loi
visant à accélérer la production
d'énergie renouvelable le présent projet
de loi constitue l'un des principaux
piliers de la stratégie énergétique
française cette stratégie est
structurante en ce qu'elle est à la
croisée des enjeux climatiques
d'indépendance et de souveraineté nous
approvisionnements énergétiques comme de
l'accès l'acceptabilité sociale de cette
transition qui bouleverse nos modes de
vie et présuppose l'exemplarité et
solidarité pour préserver cohésion et
adhésion des populations aux efforts
demandés
aujourd'hui nous constatons que la
France est en retard dans le déploiement
des moyens de production d'énergie
renouvelable et dans la structuration
des filières des carbonées par rapport à
nos voisins européens mais aussi
d'autres pays plusieurs facteurs
expliquent ce retard la lourdeur et la
complexité de nos procédures
administratives il est donc de notre
devoir de les fluidifier tout en
respectant à la fois les riverains les
contraintes environnementales les
contraintes urbanistiques et tout en
limitant au maximum l'artifice
l'artificialisation des sols
deuxième point un manque d'acceptabilité
et d'attractivité des projets liés à un
manque de concertation des populations
et des élus
manque d'appropriation au niveau local
qui pourrait être améliorée avec une
meilleure répartition de la valeur et
par une auto-consommation ce qui
permettrait également de favoriser des
projets innovants tels que la production
d'azote d'hydrogène ou de gaz porté
face à ce constat et compte tenu de la
situation internationale actuelle il
nous faut agir rapidement sur la
planification du déploiement
notre feuille de route en la matière
reconnaît à la fois l'importance
cruciale et stratégique du nucléaire
comme celui des énergies renouvelables
la souveraineté énergétique et
carbonisation les dés carbonations
pardon sont des points cruciaux de cette
stratégie ce projet de loi s'inscrit
donc dans cette feuille de route et
prévoit des mesures structurantes et
nécessaires pour le déploiement des
énergies
le groupe Horizon est apparenté tient à
saluer ce texte présenté par le
gouvernement et le travail déjà effectué
au Sénat qui a permis d'y apporter des
apports précieux qu'il faut néanmoins
préciser et améliorer
simplification des procédures et
réduction des délais d'autorisation des
projets obligations renforcée
d'installations d'énergie solaire sur de
grandes surfaces de bâtiments mesures
spécifiques au déploiement de l'éolien
en mer para partage territorial de la
valeur ajoutée des produits des projets
d'énergie renouvelables le groupe
horizon et imparenté tiendra à renforcer
l'ambition de ce texte lors de son
examen en commission
merci beaucoup madame la ministre
je vais en profiter pour prendre
d'autres points auquel j'ai pas répondu
on a évoqué l'autre mère et je veux
manifester mon ma disponibilité pour
travailler évidemment sur ce sujet là ce
sont des zones non interconnectées
souvent parentaux de notre politique
énergétique et donc les la situation
énergétique est souvent plus
problématique que celle de la métropole
donc je pense important effectivement de
pouvoir accompagner ces zones notamment
dans leur PPE ça c'est pour la question
posée tout à l'heure et dernier point
sur le retour aux particuliers je
réponds à la question précédente
je rappelle que dans les réseaux de
chaleur les particuliers bénéficient de
prix plus faibles et ils ne sont pas
égaux sur le territoire par rapport au
coût des réseaux de chaleur et que ce
sont des politiques menées par des
collectivités publiques et donc je me
permets d'utiliser cet exemple là parce
que que ce soit sur les PPA ou sur le
retour pour les
habitants d'avoir le bénéfice d'une
installation d'énergie renouvelable ont
tout été de cause on peut prendre cet
exemple là qui existe et qui fonctionne
bien sur le territoire c'est une
politique publique de collectivités
territoriale de savoir sur quoi elle
porte les efforts et comment elle
rendent la valeur aux habitants
pour le groupe écologiste nupes la
parole est à Charles Fournier
si ça fonctionne merci Monsieur les
présidents madame la ministre mesdames
Messieurs les rapporteurs chers
collègues alors les écologistes je
perdrai pas trop de temps dans
l'introduction de mon discours sont
favorables aux énergies renouvelables et
le 10 depuis longtemps et Paris sur un
triptyque reposant sur la sobriété
l'efficacité énergétique et les énergies
renouvelables pour autant quand ce texte
est arrivé dans sa première version nous
avons fait deux critiques et oui
monsieur botterel vous avez raison il y
aura des critiques sur le calendrier et
je vais en remettre une petite couche
parce que madame la ministre vous dites
que nous sommes à la fin de la fac nous
sommes au milieu de la PPE nous sommes
toujours au milieu d'une PPE mais à
quelques mois de sa révision et donc
c'est c'est bien ça qui est mis qui est
mis en critique et finalement on a le
sentiment que le choix est un peu déjà
fait alors que nous sommes toujours
effectivement dans une PPE qui prévoit
de réduire de 50% le nucléaire et
d'augmenter les énergies renouvelables
ça c'est le premier point le deuxième
point c'est que nous avons des
divergences sur le diagnostic tout
serait la faute des procédures si les
énergies renouvelables ne se développent
pas il ne semble pas qu'il s'agisse de
problèmes de procédure ou du droit de
l'environnement qu'il faudrait du coup
d'être tricoté pour rendre possible le
déploiement des énergies renouvela nous
avons des problèmes de planification
nous avons des problèmes de partage de
la valeur nous avons des problèmes
d'organisation du pilotage à l'échelle
du territoire nous avons des problèmes
associés l'ensemble de nos concitoyens
dans dans ses choix il y a eu des
problèmes politiques récurrents ou un
pas en avant trois pas en arrière et et
une difficulté à porter ce sujet de
manière volontariste alors partant d'un
diagnostic que nous partageons pas nous
avons néanmoins abordé ce texte c'est le
Sénat il y a apporté quelques éléments
qui nous paraissent majeurs depuis le
début nous le disions il faut mettre de
la planification dans ce texte elle
arrive nous regarderons avec attention
les propositions qui qui sont faites il
me semble que le couple région bloque
communal est un bon couple pour piloter
organiser de la planification ascendante
qui vient compléter la planification
descendante mais c'est tout ce mécanisme
qu'il faut rendre le plus le plus
pertinent possible nous regardons ce
texte aussi en étant des défenseurs de
la biodiversité et il nous semble qu'on
peut développer les énergies
renouvelables en ayant en réduisant le
plus possible l'impact sur la
biodiversité et pour ça tout ce qui dans
ce texte vise à réduire le code de
l'environnement la protection des
espèces évidemment nous aurons des
positions contre et elle s'expriment dès
le travail le travail en commission nous
considérons aussi que sur le partage de
la valeur se partagent de la valeur doit
se faire par le biais des collectivités
territoriales par de la redistribution
permettant des services publics et que
nous pouvons alors plus loin que ce qui
existe aujourd'hui plus loin
en volume parce qu'il nous semble que
cette répartition n'est aujourd'hui pas
équilibrée et puis une meilleure
répartition entre tout tous les tous les
acteurs quand ce partage de la valeur
nous pensons qu'on peut améliorer les
concertations et que ça c'est une nature
à accélérer les énergies renouvelables
nous pensons aussi que la modulation
tarifaire et vous l'avez évoqué dans
votre introduction est une manière de
garantir une meilleure répartition des
énergies renouvela dans le territoire
c'est une vieille revendication et si
elle est satisfaite ce sera un progrès
important en lien avec avec la
planification et puis et puis enfin tout
ça ne sera possible sans le renforcement
des moyens de l'État et notamment les
moyens dans les Dréal dans les autorités
environnementales
madame la ministre
je suis répondre donc sur deux points il
y a toute une liste de sujets je pense
que on y reviendra dans le détail sur la
modulation tarifaire effectivement je
vous ai indiqué ma disponibilité pour
travailler sur la question des
renfoncements des moyens de l'État parce
que c'est une question qui est
récurrente je veux le redire ici vous ou
en tout cas le projet loi de finances
comporte un renforcement des moyens la
direction générale énergie climat et des
dreals spécifiquement pour venir en
appui du renforcement de l'instruction
des dossiers d'énergie renouvelables je
précise une chose le plan énergie
renouvelable nous l'avons
conçu en reprenant tout l'historique des
projets bloqués ces derniers mois voir
ces dernières années et en recherchant
projet par projet les raisons et donc
c'est comme ça que nous avons adressé
chaque difficulté qu'il s'agisse du
consente ancieux des procédures
administratives des moyens je passais
détails merci beaucoup monsieur vu le
franc pour le groupe GDR
merci monsieur le Président bien notre
groupe GDR députés communistes
rappellent les lignes rouges qu'il met
au texte bien évidemment d'abord la base
du contexte nous l'avons 100 fois répété
le débat confisqué sur l'état
d'utilisation de EDF et la scission des
filières nucléaires d'une part ENR
d'autre part puisque la private la
privatisation des ENR reste la
trajectoire selon nous promise à cela le
calendrier le départ inversé on l'a dit
je n'y reviens pas sur le texte lui-même
j'ai dit notre opposition modèle donc
économique qui a guidé le développement
des on-r électriques et les manches
selon nous de dérégulation majeures et
concurrentielle du marché en gardant ce
cadre y compris via les PPA booster vous
prévoyez d'abaisser par ailleurs les
conditions de consultation des acteurs
de terrain et de dispenser plus avant
les projets de l'indispensable examen
approfondie sur les effets sur
l'environnement le cadre de vie et la
biodiversité la université cette fameuse
grande cause nationale qui est balayée
par la raison impérative d'intérêt
public majeur qui pour nous est un
véritable ou case vous considérez vous
considérez que les procédures à
différentes sont causes du retard des
projets nous affirmons au contraire que
la purement soigneuse exigeant des
propositions à vie contrarments élément
de résolution des conflits d'usage est
le seul garant de l'aboutissement de
bons projets accepté de manière éclairée
ainsi vous forcez la marche au risque
selon nous de multiplier les conflits et
de mettre plus à mal l'acceptabilité
sociale des ENR d'ailleurs le préfet
référent le fond de garantie la régul la
régularisation des irrégularités le
droit de recours menacé sont autant
autant de dispositifs que vous placez du
côté des porteurs de projets et à
contrario
les populations et les acteurs locaux
vain de confirmer votre volonté de
réinscrire votre proposition de partage
de la valeur vers les riverains
désinstallations ENR c'est vous le savez
pour nous une atteinte inacceptable à
l'égalité des usagers devant le service
public de l'énergie et une piètre
tentative de tordre le bras aux acteurs
locaux alors où notre mixte est parmi
les plus décarbonés à l'échelle
européenne la priorité que vous mettiez
d'ailleurs en voiture balai serait celle
des ENR terniques en capacité d'extraire
la consommation de chaleur des sources
fossiles encore massivement prégnantes
de l'ordre de 60%. en l'état pour nous
c'est un texte de précipitation résumé
de votre propre formule structurelle et
transitoire qui précipitent la division
des Français sur une dimension
essentielle de notre souveraineté
nationale et un service de première
nécessité
madame la ministre
je voudrais rappeler que les PPA ça
s'adresse notamment aux collectivités
locales et que donc ça porte des enjeux
de service public je le redis c'est très
exactement les mêmes choses que les
réseaux de chaleur alors je comprends
pas ce qui fonctionne en chaleur ne
fonctionnerait pas en électricité ou en
installation de méthane le ripping j'ai
déjà répondu les procédures j'aimerais
juste comprendre une chose c'est
pourquoi ce qui fonctionne dans les
autres pays européens ne fonctionnerait
pas en France en quoi le fait de prendre
en compte ce qui fonctionne bien et a
permis dans les autres pays européens de
tenir leur trajectoire de développement
des énergies renouvelables et
effectivement d'avoir des succès et de
ne pas être en retard par rapport à leur
engagement ne fonctionnerait pas en
France et en quoi ça serait un recul par
rapport à ce que nous avons déjà enfin
déjà dernière chose sur l'égalité devant
l'énergie je le repose c'est un problème
philosophique c'est la même chose pour
les transports le coût du ticket de
transport public elle même d'une ville à
l'autre c'est la même chose pour la
cantine c'est la même chose pour l'accès
à des services publics minimum et c'est
aussi la liberté d'exercices des
collectivités locales dont on parle ici
merci
pour le groupe liberté indépendante
outre-mer et territoire la parole est à
Nathalie bassire
merci monsieur le Président alors
Messieurs les Présidents madame la
ministre madame et Messieurs les
rapporteurs chers collègues en matière
de politique énergétique une question ne
devrait plus se poser et pourtant elle
semble toujours faire des bas celle de
l'accélération du déploiement des
énergies renouvelables nous le redisons
la lutte contre les émissions de gaz à
effet de serre passera par
l'électrification de nos usages doit-on
répéter que le nucléaire à lui seul ne
sera répondre à ses besoins croissants
faut-il rappeler que les prochaines
centrales ne pourront de toute façon pas
voir le jour avant une dizaine d'années
notre avenir énergétique passera par une
montée en puissance des énergies
renouvelables ce préalable étant posé il
faut désormais créer les conditions
nécessaires à un déploiement massif
c'est l'objet du projet de loi dont nous
débutons l'examen aujourd'hui à juste
titre les sénateurs ont considéré que la
célébration passerait par une meilleure
planification sans elle pas
d'appropriation ni d'acceptation par
chaque habitant des projets qui seront
développés dans leur bassin de vie pour
pour autant le dispositif voté au Sénat
n'était pas satisfaisant il était au
mieux redondant au pire contradictoire
avec celui proposé par le gouvernement à
l'article 3 l'amendement de réécriture
proposée par la majorité tente
d'apporter de la cohérence tout en
préservant une approche ascendante à
laquelle nous sommes attachés mais à
bien y regarder ce nouveau dispositif
porte deux faiblesses majeures nous
craignons qui ne soient pas suffisamment
incitatif au déploiement là où les
énergies renouvelables font défaut et au
contraire pas suffisamment des incisives
pardon dans les territoires arrivés à
saturation concernant l'acceptabilité
des énergies renouvelables toujours le
texte propose que ceux qui subissent les
externalités négatives résultant des
installations de production d'énergie
soit compensées pour séduisances
contrairement au sénateur nous estimons
que ce n'est pas aux communes de toucher
inversement forfaitaire annuel mais au
riverains directement concernés à partir
du moment où ils habitent dans un
périmètre allant jusqu'à 5 km autour de
l'implantation je vais finir mon propos
en évoquant une problématique qui m'est
cher la question du déploiement des
énergies renouvelables dans les zones
non interconnectées dans nos territoires
ultramarins et encore atteindre une
forme d'autonomie énergétique nous
impose de composer avec les ressources
de nos territoires là-bas aussi le
soleil est parfois l'éolien en leur
pertinence mais d'autres sources telles
que la géothermie mérite elles aussi
d'être davantage soutenu notre groupe
proposera plusieurs amendements pour
accélérer la transition énergétique dans
ces zones en espérant les voir se
concrétiser dans un titre dédié aux
zones non interconnectées globalement
nos propositions lors de l'examen de ce
texte s'inscriront toutes dans cette
dynamique plus pousser plus loin
l'ambition de ce texte afin de permettre
à la France de rattraper son retard dans
la transition bas carbone je vous
remercie
alors sur l'article sur l'article 3
effectivement on distingue on en
discutera ce sera je pense un des gros
objets de discussion du texte je
rappelle juste que la planification
tient compte du potentiel des
territoires elle tient compte aussi de
ce qu'il y a déjà été réalisé c'était
une discussions importantes au Sénat
ceux qui ont déjà fait beaucoup de tels
ou telle énergie doivent-ils en faire
encore plus et la modulation tarifaire
est aussi une façon de rééquilibrer les
territoires et je pense que ça répond à
votre souci sur la compensation des
externalités négatives je veux dire
nettement ici le sujet enfin les
énergies des installations d'énergie
renouvelables ce ne sont pas des
externalités négatives ce sont des
externalités positives c'est l'accès à
la promesse d'une énergie bas carbone
pas cher abondante et je rappelle que
typiquement à un moment où on évoque des
risques d'équilibre entre production et
demande
publicité sur le territoire français
lorsque vous avez des unités qui
produisent et bien vous avez une
résilience qui est plus forte et c'est
pas sur ce territoire là que risque de
se passer des problèmes entre offre
enfin production et demande
d'électricité donc c'est plutôt de
rendre aux habitants le fait qu'ils ont
permis à une énergie bas carbone et
compétitive d'être produite c'est ce que
nous cherchons merci beaucoup alors nous
allons passer aux questions
individuelles nous avons noté madame
bellucco monsieur Bricout monsieur
Vermorel monsieur Decker monsieur Boni
monsieur Vatin si votre nom n'a pas été
cité levé bien la main et nos
administrateurs vont vous noter je vous
propose de commencer alors c'est une
minute par question prend la totalité
des questions à la chaîne et ensuite
madame la ministre pourrait répondre et
Madame la rapporteur également nous
commençons par Madame Belugo c'est à
vous
merci merci Messieurs les Présidents
madame la ministre chers collègues il
est indispensable de développer
particulièrement l'éolien terrestre et
c'est sur ça que je veux revenir tous
les scénarios énergétiques convergent
sur ce point à ce sujet ce gouvernement
n'est pourtant pas tout à fait à la
hauteur ni dans les mots ni dans les
actes dans les mots d'abord l'ensemble
des acteurs de l'éolien du WWF aux
entreprises de la filière en passant par
l'association amorce s'accorde sur le
fait qu'il serait très risqué pour
l'atteinte de la neutralité carbone en
France d'étaler dans le temps l'objectif
de développement de l'éolien terrestre
tels annoncé par le président de la
République lors du discours de Belfort
en février dernier
le faible développement de l'éolien
terrestre n'est pas dû au droit de
l'environnement ni à ses procédures mais
un manque de volonté politique pour
preuve j'en veux pour preuve certains
préfets ne signent pas d'autorisation
pour les parcs éoliens si le ou les
maires concernés n'en veulent pas dans
les actes donc ce n'est pas qu'une
question de procédure c'est une question
de moyens humains de participation des
communes et de consignes préfet madame
la ministre au lendemain de la COP 27
revenez-vous sur le discours de Belfort
qui risque de mettre en péril notre
capacité à atteindre nos objectifs en
2050 et vous engagez-vous à proposer un
PLFR dès le début de 2023 pour abonder
les effectifs des services déconcentrés
de l'État merci beaucoup monsieur
Bricout
merci monsieur le rapporteur madame la
Présidente l'accélération de la
production des énergies renouvelables
études en même temps effectivement
qu'une nécessité je crois que nous en
convenons ici moi le premier mais ne dis
pas supportable que des territoires
entiers soient sacrifiés sur l'hôtel
d'une transition énergétique qui ne
saurait être concertés
qui fonctionne mal en tous les cas et
qui est déséquilibré avec de les hauts
de France Hélène en terre sacrifiée avec
les élus et les populations qui se
sentent plus respectées pour qu'il y ait
acceptabilité il faut qu'il y ait bien
sûr une répartition juste de l'effort
consenti et mon territoire a déjà
d'ailleurs beaucoup donné madame la
ministre le zonage tel qu'il est
envisagé avec une impossibilité de
s'opposer ne va-t-il pas être
contre-productif là où le ras-le-bol
devient légitime devant les paysages
saturés je vous remercie
merci beaucoup monsieur va Morel
si merci Messieurs les Présidents madame
la ministre dans votre propos
introductif il y a quelques minutes vous
avez déclaré devant nos commissions que
vous souhaitiez je cite faire confiance
aux maires en leur permettant d'avoir le
dernier mot ils auront un avis conforme
sur les zones prioritaires qui
comprennent leur commune j'aimerais que
vous puissiez clarifier vos propos
pourriez-vous remplacer sur les zones
prioritaires par sur les projets éoliens
en clair et pour vous paraphraser les
mers auront un avis conforme sur les
projets éoliens qui comprennent leur
commune je vous remercie bien monsieur
Descartes
Messieurs les Présidents madame la
ministre ce projet de loi qui a pour
objet d'accélérer le déploiement des
énergies renouvelables c'est à
l'objectif affiché de doubler la
capacité de production de l'éolienne
terrestre ce qui pose un manquablement
la question de l'acceptabilité de ces
projets par nos concitoyens c'est la
raison pour laquelle il est
indispensable que nous parvenions à
poser en toute transparence les
conditions d'un développement apaisé et
consenti le Sénat introduit dans le
projet initial un chapitre entier sur la
planification vous l'avez rappelé il est
à mes yeux importantes conserver un
processus robuste d'identification des
zones profites propice pardon et par
voie de conséquence de celles qui ne le
sont pas et où tout déploiement devrait
être interdit ceci tout en permettant
aux élus concernés au premier chef les
mers et élus municipaux de définir
infinie la pertinence des projets et de
se prononcer en émettant un avis réputé
conforme madame la ministre seriez-vous
favorable à cette disposition qui
revient à faire confiance aux élus comme
là évoqué mon collègue merci beaucoup
merci Messieurs les Présidents madame
Lamine chers collègues le projet loi que
vous nous proposez prévoir d'installer
des panneaux solaires partout où cela
est possible d'aider les routiers ou
toitures en ville en passant par les
ombrières de parking certaines de ces
options peuvent poser question étant sûr
de vraiment vouloir défricher nos bois
pour y installer des panneaux est-il
bien nécessaire d'introduire des
entorses sur loi littoral ou en montagne
pour quelques cellules photovoltaïques
de plus vous renforcez les obligations
de couverture des parkings en nombril
hier qui vont non seulement poser sur
les acteurs de la grande distribution
mais aussi sur les petites communes
celle-ci déjà soumises au zéro
artificialisation nette devront renoncer
à des projets d'aménagement tout cela
parce que des panneaux ont été posés sur
des parkings qu'elles auraient bien
voulu reconvertir astanzion donc au
risque de développement anarchique du
solaire au mitage et l'installation de
ces énergies intermittentes qui ne
produit pas en soirée au moment des pays
de consommation dont on ne maîtrise pas
les matériaux et minéraux de base et
dans les marchés seront essentiellement
des entreprises étrangères qu'à l'action
le gouvernement a-t-il prévu en
parallèle de ce projet de loi pour
encourager le développement d'une
filière française merci merci Monsieur
Vatin
Messieurs les Présidents madame la
ministre chers collègues depuis des
années les gouvernements successifs
engagent des crédits importants pour
soutenir la rénovation énergétique des
bâtiments censé permettre de faire des
économies sur le chauffage des logements
ce chauffage est en grande partie assuré
en France par la production électrique
du fait de notre avantage historique
dans le nucléaire optimiser les systèmes
de chauffage permet donc de faire
réaliser des économies au ménage et
libère de l'électricité pour d'autres
usages mais des carbone finalement peu
notre mix énergétique la production
d'eau chaude sanitaire qu'il est peu
facile d'optimiser et repose en partie
sur le gaz offre en revanche une vraie
marge de transition écologique elle
pourrait être produite à partir de
géothermie laquelle dispose comme pour
le chauffage d'un potentiel sur de
nombreux territoires mais quasiment
absentes de votre projet de loi c'est
même pire depuis le Grenelle la
production n'a augmenté que de 30%, mais
n'a contribué qu'à hauteur de 1% à
l'essor des eénères en France Merci vous
qui cherchez absolument à augmenter les
statistiques des énergies renouvelables
ne pas avoir exploré cette voix merci
Monsieur potier
merci pour pour économiser des sols
agricoles naturels il faut optimiser
toutes les surfaces artificialisées nous
avons deux propositions phares il s'agit
pas Madame la mise mais je crois que
c'était juste une question de malentendu
des DDC de VNF mais de l'ensemble de du
domaine public fluvial qui doit être
optimisé je pense aussi de relief
notamment sur le domaine public fluvial
et puis les zones d'activité économiques
même si une rédactions ne sont pas
forcément heureuses dans cette première
phase en commission sont des véritables
lieux d'optimisation notamment en
combinant que la chaleur fatale de
certaines activités économiques donc
lieu de production et de consommation
tous les acteurs concernés nous disent
que c'est un des lieux qui va nous faire
économiser des milliers d'hectares
agricoles et naturels parce que nos
zones d'activités ont une acceptabilité
et des opportunités déficiences
énergétiques à nul autre pareil enfin
sur la méthanisation le groupe
socialiste a très heureux de non
seulement de non pas de conclure le
débat sur la méthanisation mais de
l'ouvrir en vue de la PPE nous pensons
en effet que la méditation qui fait
appel exclusivement aux effluants
d'élevage ou de station d'opération
doivent être identifiées comme tel merci
Madame guetter
avec
ce festival de diversion sur le poids
des normes le contentieux la
participation du public qui sont pour
vous les boucs émissaires du retard
français pourtant la mission flash que
j'ai menée avec les autres corps à
porteurs la montrer c'est que dans ce
projet de loi vous ne mettez pas les
moyens financiers et humains nécessaires
pour accélérer réellement on assiste à
une pénurie dans les services chargés de
l'instruction des projets pénuries dans
les juridictions administratives pour
examiner le contentieux pénurie encore
chez les opérateurs de l'État je pense
au serema et à l'ADEME l'administration
a été victime pendant plus de 10 ans de
coupe méthodique d'effectifs que nous
dénonçons et continuerons dénoncer et
France énergie éolienne estimait par
exemple qu'il fallait 50 et P
supplémentaires pour les projets éoliens
offshore à la DGEC et 52+ pour les
projets terrestres vous avez éliminé nos
amendements dans le PLF avec un 49-3
qu'attendez-vous pour donner à l'état
les moyens d'assumer son rôle de
planificateur dans la bifurcation
énergétique dans ce projet de loi merci
merci Madame trouvé
merci monsieur le Président Madame la
Ministre j'aurais une question sur la
grivevoltaïsme et une autre sur la
méthanisation agricole et donc sur une
fine et les risques qui peuvent peser
sur la production agricole je rappelle
que nous sommes si l'on sort le vin
sur les productions alimentaires
largement en valeur importateur net avec
un recul année après année de notre
surface agricole donc il y a aujourd'hui
un gros enjeu à ce que aucune surface
agricole aujourd'hui ne soit mise en
danger quoi qu'il arrive bon le premier
problème il est que il y a pas
d'objectif chiffrés ça on l'a dit déjà
dans dans ce projet de loi nerf et donc
on ne comprend pas qu'elle pourrait être
la part en fait liée à la méthanisation
agricole ou à la grivevoltaïsme au
développement des énergies renouvelables
alors évidemment cela vaut une autre
question concernant l'agrivoltaïsme et
la méthanisation agricole
est-ce qu'il y a qu'est-ce qui est-ce
qu'il y a des garanties supplémentaires
qui pourront être apportées sur la
grivevoltaïsme évitant toute tout
détournement de face agricole toute tout
projet
d'agrovitalisme qui qui ferait diminuer
la production la production agricole
deuxièmement sur la mécanisation
agricole est-ce qu'il y a des garanties
de non-artificialisation des terres
voilà Monsieur Lamirault
oui merci monsieur le président madame
la ministre je voulais juste revenir
rapidement sur un article que le
gouvernement entendu sur
l'utilisation des
des toits qui aujourd'hui ont de
l'amiante parce que je pensais au
contraire qu'on aurait pu le développer
à d'autres toits c'était un ajout du
Sénat que de favoriser l'installation de
photovoltaïques sur des toits en amiante
agricoles et je trouvais que peut-être
on pouvait au contraire l'étendre à
l'ensemble des sociétés et des usines
merci Madame brulbois merci monsieur le
Président Madame le Ministre la
valorisation énergétique des CSR
combustibles solides de récupération est
intéressante elle permet de produire de
la chaleur ou de l'électricité or en
France le nécessaire ont toujours le
statut de déchets qui semble bloquer le
développement de cette filière alors que
nous enfouissons encore beaucoup trop de
revis de tri d'autre part il se
développe une des installations de
photovoltaïques sur les chez les
particuliers avec
autoconsommation mais sans revente
d'électricité elles font donc leur
électricité au voisinage et je trouve
que c'est une pratique très intéressante
coopérative et qu'il faut qu'il nous
faudrait encourager
merci beaucoup madame bateau merci
Monsieur le monsieur les présidents
madame la ministre il n'y a aucun chemin
pour atteindre nos objectifs climatiques
qui ne commencent par réduire
drastiquement la consommation d'énergie
et la diviser par deux et donc je
regrette qu'on ne fasse pas les choses
dans l'ordre que le débat commence par
se concentrer par les moyens de
production alors que l'urgence absolue
qui est aussi une urgence sociale c'est
de réduire la consommation d'énergie
deuxième mot pour regretter une erreur
de diagnostic le retard français dans le
développement des énergies renouvelables
ne s'expliquent pas par la préservation
de la biodiversité et le code de
l'environnement il s'explique par une
absence totale de volonté politique et
le fait que la nation s'est réfugiée
pendant très longtemps dans la croyance
que le nucléaire allait la mettre à
l'abri des difficultés énergétiques que
nous connaissons aujourd'hui enfin je
crois que ce texte malheureusement ne va
pas régler les problèmes qu'il cache en
fait le texte de relance d'un nouveau
programme nucléaire et surtout que sur
les énergies renouvelables j'espère
qu'on aura le débat il se trompe de
modèle ça doit être des énergies dans la
main des territoires ça doit être des
énergies décentralisées et donc ça
suppose une adaptation de l'ensemble du
schéma énergétique qui a été celui de la
France pendant des années merci beaucoup
madame Ménil ferme
réfléchir ce texte dans le sens de ces
de ces trois points merci beaucoup
monsieur Meurin
merci monsieur le Président Madame la
Ministre pour défendre votre texte vous
avez dit tout à l'heure pourquoi on ne
ferait pas ceux qui marchent dans les
autres pays qui tiennent leur
trajectoire en matière d'énergie
renouvelable et bien précisément parce
que c'est pays ont mix énergétique bien
plus carbonées que nous je l'ai rappelé
tout à l'heure pour l'Allemagne qui a un
mix énergétique carboné fois 10% par
rapport à la France notre nucléaire fait
de nous les champions du bas carbone je
renverse donc votre question pourquoi
vous obstinez dans les énergies dites
renouvelables mais en fait intermittente
qui nous font ouvrir pardon des
centrales à charbon très carbonés alors
que nous sommes les champions du bas
carbone et que nous n'investissons
aujourd'hui pas assez dans la dans une
vraie vision énergétique d'avenir sur
l'hydrogène la géothermie etc dont vous
nous expliquez qu'on attend aujourd'hui
un plan qui aurait dû à mon sens être
intégré dans un texte plus global sur
notre vision énergétique je vous
remercie
bien je crois que j'ai épuisé la liste
des questions individuelles est-ce que
tout le monde a pu poser sa question
très bien Madame la Ministre c'est à
vous pour une réponse globale
alors madame sur les effectifs je le
redis les effectifs sont renforcés dans
le projet de loi de finance que ce soit
au niveau central ou au niveau des
concentré vous évoquez également des
consignes au préfet cela déjà été fait
par une circulaire du 15 septembre qui
donne des consignes très précises au
préfet de façon à ce que le déploiement
des énergies renouvelables soit une
priorité de leur action qu'il puisse par
ailleurs agir sur Oui qu'ils puissent
par ailleurs agir sur le
comment sur les points de blocage qu'il
puisse cartographier pour et accompagner
les élus locaux dans la détermination de
nouveaux projets et qu'il fasse des
revues de projet très régulières et nous
rendent compte lorsque des projets sont
bloqués de pourquoi ils sont bloqués et
de comment on peut les débloquer donc je
pense qu'on ne peut pas dire qu'on
manque de détermination politique ni que
ce soit le point de blocage puisque ce
point-là a déjà été traité monsieur
Brico sur le zonage je veux rappeler ici
que évidemment l'enjeu c'est d'en faire
des hommages incitatifs c'est-à-dire à
la fois qu'ils soient porté à la
connaissance des porteurs de projets et
qui donc vont immédiatement créer le
lien avec les élus locaux et permettent
de développer ses projets qui soient
prises en compte dans des appels à
projets soit spécifiques pour ces
hommages soit dans lequel le fait
d'appartenir assaisonnage rapportera on
va dire des points supplémentaires et on
tiendra compte dans la définition de
saisonnage c'est tout l'intérêt d'une
planification de ce qui a déjà été fait
vous mentionnez effectivement des
paysages saturés par des éoliennes
terrestres je pense que vous faites
référence à votre territoire et en tout
état de cause l'objectif n'est pas de
remettre sur des territoires qui sont
déjà fortement orientées sur un type
d'énergie renouvelable encore plus de
pression pour qu'ils produisent toujours
de la même énergie renouvelable c'est de
bien répartir sur l'ensemble de
territoires l'effort est donc ça va dans
le sens et les propositions en matière
de modulation des tarifs peuvent aider
en ce sens
monsieur Valmorel s'agissant du veto des
mers je me permets de vous renvoyer au
comité au communiqué de presse de
l'Association des Maires Rhodes France
qui explicitent très bien pourquoi eux
ne sont pas demandeurs de ce type de
disposition et je leur fais assez
confiance pour savoir peut-être mieux
que quiconque ce qui est bon pour amer
ils sont très nombreux ils sont sur le
territoire ce sont des mers ruraux et
ils sont confrontés à la question du
développement des énergies renouvelables
il souhaite se lancer et c'est en
écoutant les associations il n'y a pas
que l'association des mers ruraux de
France qu'on peut préposition je
rappelle que intercommunalité de France
a également pris position sur ce sujet
là donc moi j'écoute les élus du
territoire j'ai eu énormément de
remontées sur cette proposition du Sénat
beaucoup de levées de boucliers des élus
de terrain et je fais droit
effectivement à leur demande ce qui
demande c'est être accompagné accompagné
en ingénierie accompagner en crédit
accompagner en cartographie accompagner
pour faire en sorte précisément d'avoir
les plusieurs porteurs de projets de
pouvoir aller plus vite sans avoir de
mauvaises surprises et c'est ce que nous
proposons de faire je me suis decarte
vous avez posé la même question que je
vous fais la même réponse
monsieur Bonnie précisément ce que nous
prévoyons dans le texte ce n'est pas de
poser du photovoltaïque sur des
territoires qui sont
naturels c'est de le poser sur des
parties délaissées dégradées donc c'est
très exactement le contraire de votre
crainte et donc ça devrait vous rassurer
de même s'agissant du photovoltaïque sur
ombrière cela ne concerne pas tous les
parkings cela concerne pas toutes les
zones de parking et comme vous le savez
il y a une disposition qui prévoit que
s'il y a une contrainte économique ou
une contrainte technique
le parking ne peut ne pas avoir à
utiliser ce registre là sur le
développement de la fier c'est une
excellente question et c'est pour ça que
nous avons engagé depuis
deux ans déjà au travers du plan de
relance d'une part puis au travers de
France des soutiens en filière en
recharge Développement
Innovation pré-industrialisation sur les
sujets d'énergie renouvelables cela
concerne aussi d'ailleurs l'hydrogène
dont je rappelle que ce n'est pas une
énergie mais un vecteur énergétique et
donc ça n'a rien à voir Monsieur Vatin
oui la chaleur est bien concernée les
concernée par tout le titre 2 désormais
mais également concernée par les mesures
que nous avons d'ores et déjà d'ores et
déjà prise dans le cadre de notre grand
plan énergie renouvelable certaines
mesures sont d'ordre
comment dire réglementaires tout ne
passe pas par la loi et c'est très bien
ça vous permet de vous concentrer sur
les sujets stratégiques monsieur potier
je note effectivement la volonté
d'associer enfin d'avoir une approche
sur l'ensemble du domaine filiable il
faut qu'on trouve la bonne rédaction et
rapproche les positions mais sur le plan
des principes rien de s'y oppose c'est
exactement la logique que nous voulons
c'est ce qui
et grosso modo
inutilisé aujourd'hui et constitue des
zones dégradées etc peut-être utilisé
pour faire du photovoltaïque sur les
zones d'activité économiques qui se
transformeraient en zone active à
énergie positive sur le plan des
principes pour tout à fait d'accord vous
trouvez la bonne réaction sur la
méthanisation c'est un point qui est
remonté au fil des travaux pas tout de
suite il faut effectivement le dire mais
qu'effectivement on passe à côté d'un
certain nombre de lisiers et compagnies
pour faire de la méthanisation premier
point sur les effluences c'est un sujet
qui est plus sensible en termes de
dépendage derrière vous le savez et donc
j'ai pas encore moi de vision très
équilibrée de rédaction qui permettent
de concilier les enjeux de sécurité
sanitaire et les enjeux d'utilisation de
cette intrant madame guettée sur les
moyens humains vous avez raison de
mentionner que ces dernières années ces
20 dernières années d'ailleurs donc ça
concerne beaucoup de gouvernements
antérieurs il y a eu des réductions
d'effectifs dans l'orbite du ministère
de la transition énergétique et
d'ailleurs dans l'orbite du ministère de
la transition écologique nous y avons
mis fin cette année nous avons renforcé
les moyens humains notamment sur la
fermière énergie renouvelable nous
utilisons également nous avons renforcé
les crédits d'études pour accompagner
les projets sur l'éolien en mer et sur
les autres technologies donc nous allons
dans le sens que vous mentionnez
peut-être pas assez mais en tout cas la
direction est prise madame trouvé sur
l'agrivoltaïsme je veux vous rassurer il
est évident que l'objectif est de
concilier souveraineté alimentaire et
souveraineté énergétique il n'est donc
pas question de remettre en cause notre
potentiel de production alimentaire et
c'est pour ça que nos privilégions
toujours des choix ou soit on a des
installations qui sont conciliables avec
la production soit on a des
installations qui sont démontables et
qui permettent de une réversibilité en
toute état de cause une limitation avec
un agris voltalisme ou c'est un
agriculteur qui fait en plus de la
production d'énergie et pas un
producteur d'énergie qui fait à côté un
peu d'agriculture c'est pas du tout le
sens de notre propos il nous avons déjà
placé un certain nombre de limites de
même que nous plaçons des limites sur la
biomasse qui est utilisée dans la
méthanisation pour que ce ne soit pas de
la biomasse à usage alimentaire
monsieur l'amirault sur la question des
toits amiante la disposition qui était
prévue c'est un rapport de mémoire donc
la suggestion c'est qu'on y travaille
mais pas forcément sous la forme d'un
rapport et pour nous ce n'est pas une
mesure d'ordre législative c'est pour ça
que nous proposerons nous proposerons
l'annulation et sur l'expérimentation
même sujet c'est pas
je dirais une mesure d'ordre législatif
ça veut pas dire que la question
n'existe pas elle est particulièrement
sensible sur ce type de construction
dans le dans le monde agricole c'est
pour ça qu'elle avait été portée par le
sénateur grimillé
sur Madame brulbois sur le statut de
décret de déchets du CSR effectivement
c'est un point sur lequel
il y a des zones d'amélioration possible
donc pas nécessairement enfin sur lequel
on est prêt à travailler sur les
installations photovoltaïques qui
permettent l'autoconsommation collective
je vous signaler qu'on vient de passer
des textes réglementaires chaque fois je
vous signale des textes réglementaires
mais nous travaillons sur tous les
étages et je pense que c'est
utile qui facilite l'autoconsommation
collective notamment en permettant
d'avoir des financements à 80% d'entrée
de jeu plutôt que
d'égrainer le financement sur cinq
années ça c'est la première chose et qui
reconnaît au facilite l'autoconsommation
collective
sur Madame bateau la question la baisse
de la consommation énergétique comme
vous l'avez pu le constater dans mon
propos introductif c'est le premier
levier que j'ai mentionné c'est à la
fois la sobriété énergétique le
changement de comportement et
l'efficacité énergétique l'utilisation
de technologique qui permet à usage égal
de baisser la consommation d'énergie
c'est un sujet sur lequel nous avons
annoncé c'est la première fois qu'on le
fait un plan sobriété énergétique sous
l'égide de la première ministre il y a
un mois et je veux noter ici que ce qui
change avec ce plan c'est que les grands
acteurs sont désormais mis sous pression
pour avancer les grandes administrations
qui ont un plan les grandes
collectivités locales qui sont engagées
souvent devant leur conseil exécutif et
les entreprises il est intéressant de
noter que trois quarts des grandes
entreprises ce sont dotées d'un plan
sobriété dont une large partie a été
présentée au dont une large partie
longue présentée en conseil
d'administration c'est donc un texte qui
ou des plans qui aujourd'hui une valeur
juridique interne mais forte
sur la question de l'absence de volonté
politique et bien c'est une bonne
nouvelle parce que il y a désormais une
volonté politique d'avancer je
permettrai pas d'adresser les 20
dernières années mais c'est je crois le
message qui vous est adressé aujourd'hui
c'est une volonté politique elle a été
très clairement indiquée à nos bras
armés sur le territoire les préfets et
donc c'est dans ce sens là que il faut
nous voir travailler sur la question de
mettre des EMR dans la main des
territoires vous avez raison de
mentionner que ce qui est en train de
changer avec
notre système énergétique c'est qu'il va
devenir de plus en plus décentralisée
avec des enjeux de fonctionnement des
réseaux avec
finalement un renversement du de
du fonctionnement entre consommation le
consommateur sera à la fois un peu
producteur et consommateur et de manière
beaucoup plus atomisée sur le territoire
ça va changer les règles du jeu les
règles de des réseaux de distribution
les règles des réseaux de transport les
modalités de pilotage tout ça est
parfaitement exact et c'est un des
grands je dirais des filles que nous
allons avoir adressé y compris
d'ailleurs sur les réseaux puisque ça va
devenir une infrastructure encore plus
stratégique que ça n'était et en plus à
l'aune du réchauffement climatique qui
risque de toucher peut-être plus les
réseaux en termes de fonctionnement que
certaines installations type centrale
nucléaire qui ont déjà été souvent gré
sur des études de très hautes chaleurs
ou de très grands froid ça sera un sujet
qui va nécessiter beaucoup
d'investissements ça sera un des enjeux
de la PPE je pense à venir sur la
géothermie je le redis à ce stade mais
si vous avez des propositions moi je
suis évidemment preneuse en termes de
procédure administrative la géothermie
bénéficie de procédures simplifiées
notamment sur
la géomie peu profonde et donc en ce
sens il nous paraît pas souhaitable de
changer ces procédures et de les
complexifier ça fonctionne notre sujet
sur la géothermie de
conforter la filière et notamment les
compétences en matière de forage puisque
pour accompagner un déploiement de
géothermie on manque de forer pour
mettre en place ces installations nous
pensons que ce sont des installations
prometteuses surtout dans le Nouveau
Monde énergétique dans lequel nous
sommes pour deux raisons la première
chose c'est qu'au regard du
réchauffement climatique vous avez un
double usage chaleur et refroidissement
avec l'usage de refroidissement va
devenir très important dans les années
qui viennent notamment sur les épisodes
climatiques de canicule et le deuxième
intérêt c'est qu'avec l'augmentation des
prix de l'énergie ce qui était
initialement une énergie avec des coûts
d'investissement assez élevé et donc un
retour sur investissement qui était très
long dans le temps devrait avoir
aujourd'hui un support plus favorable un
retour sur investissement plus rapide
qui va faciliter la mise en oeuvre de
ces projets sur monsieur Meurin nous ne
sommes pas les champions du bas carbone
je suis désolé de vous le dire il y a
pas que l'électricité dans le système
énergétique ou alors couper le chauffage
chez vous
non deux tiers de notre mix énergétique
et fossile deux tiers et donc c'est ça
le sujet qui est adressé vous avez
raison de dire que l'électricité est à
92% des carbonées et c'est notre
fierté mais il y a quand même un gros
éléphant dans la pièce qui sont les deux
tiers de notre système énergétique le
nucléaire c'est 20% de notre système
énergétique c'est donc minoritaire dans
notre système énergétique la deuxième
chose Monsieur Merin c'est que
l'hydrogène ce n'est pas une énergie
c'est un vecteur énergétique donc il
vous faut pour produire de l'hydrogène
de l'énergie si vous n'avez pas
d'énergie il n'y a pas d'hydrogène et
donc il faut bien l'en trouver de
l'énergie c'est le sujet et puis sur la
géothermie j'ai déjà répondu et puis je
veux vous signaler le 4 pays comme la
Suède
qui aujourd'hui ont un mix énergétique
avec une part de NR très élevée ils ont
aussi un petit peu de nucléaire et qui
ont sont des champions du baccarbone
avec beaucoup d'énergie renouvelables et
qui manifestement résolument le problème
du pilotage je ne peux pas non plus
entendre que on ne peut piloter qu'avec
des centrales à gaz c'est vrai que les
centrales à gaz sont avec un une énergie
qui est très probablement la plus facile
à piloter c'est parfaitement exact mais
la France peut quand même se prévaloir
de savoir piloter de l'énergie nucléaire
c'est d'ailleurs une de nos fiertés
aussi nous savons mieux piloter
l'énergie nucléaire montée et descendre
que d'autres pays qui fonctionnent
souvent en base sans faire ces
modulations c'est le premier point nous
avons l'hydraulique pour piloter et puis
nous travaillons sur la diminution de la
de la comment dire
du caractère intermittent des énergies
lorsque vous coupez dans une
installation du de l'éolien et du
photovoltaïque vous améliorez
sensiblement
le taux d'usage par exemple ce sont des
développements qui ont cours dans la
péninsule ibérique et qui permet de
monter au-delà de 50 60 % et donc de
diminuer fortement l'intermittence et
c'est là aussi où nos investissements
dans la recherche et le développement
ont un sens c'est que on le voit bien le
nucléaire c'est une énergie qui prend du
temps à développer et aujourd'hui
peut-être on sera mieux le faire demain
mais aujourd'hui il faut 15 ans pour
sortir un réacteur nucléaire 15 ans dans
un schéma où il y a pas d'obstacles ou
de problèmes dans la conduite du projet
donc pendant 15 ans on fait quoi et vous
avez un sujet de gestion des déchets
voilà c'est connu on améliore mais c'est
deux sujets qu'il faut aborder de
l'autre côté sur les énergies
renouvelables on travaille sur
l'intermittence on travaille sur le
stockage en particulier le stockage de
haute densité il n'y a pas une énergie
qui soit parfaite certaines consomment
peu d'espace d'autres beaucoup certaines
ne plaisent pas dans les paysages
d'autres sont invisibles ou concentrés
certaines sont plus ou moins
intermittentes à la fin de la journée il
y a pas d'énergie qui permet de répondre
à tous nos besoins et c'est pour ça
qu'ils font un panier énergétique qui
soit varié et y compris de la chaleur
renouvelable et là je rejoins les
expressions qui ont été faites sur tous
les bancs
bien merci Madame la Ministre merci
beaucoup pour vos réponses si madame
messieurs les rapporteurs n'ont rien
ajouté monsieur le président
allez-y je vous propose simplement
d'abord vous remercier monsieur le
Président pour votre accueil dans votre
salle de commission le temps que les
rapporteurs le rapporteur alors on
commence par qui par Monsieur par le
rapporteur se met en place je vous
propose qu'on fasse 5 minutes de
suspension et de sorte à ce que nous
puissions commencer les débats en toute
sérénité
c'est ici très bien et il me reste plus
qu'à vous souhaiter monsieur le
Président et mesdames messieurs les
députés de la commission Développement
Durable un bon courage pour l'examen des
articles que vous allez étudier et pour
les commissaires éco rendez-vous
directement jeudi 9h30 pour l'examen
merci